before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys join our memberships
to become a part of the live chat this
live stream we're doing a full members
only live chat this live stream so if
you want to be a part of it sign up we
have two tiers a five dollar tier and a
ten dollar tier the ten dollar tier i
believe we have two vlogs that are up
right now we also started a twitch page
and a facebook page so go follow that
also go follow my instagram just dot
pearly things i'm trying i think i just
hit 20k so what's the next goal 25k i
guess yes ma'am
on top of that all super chats that are
sent during the stream will be read
sometimes they get built up but you know
we can't be interrupting the show every
five minutes so every like 30 40 minutes
we'll read super chats
um on top of that
if you want to come on the show dm eddie
his link is in the description
so today we have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age
your relationship status and what you do
for a living so starting with you
my name is mahdi tijani
relation at my age i'm 32 years old
relation relationship status married we
can get to that in a bit
and basically i do youtube now
hi everybody my name is lydia rose i am
32 years old i am in a happy
relationship with my soulmate so it's
amazing
um i do quite a lot of things i'm an
entrepreneur creative freelance youth
worker content creator social
commentator
hi guys my name is takena um you can
call me susie because no one knows how
to pronounce my name
i'm 21 years old i'm a digital marketer
and i am single
okay it's michael king yeah you should
already know me already man but anyway
if you don't michael king um classified
age classified
uh relationship status yeah youtuber so
yeah michael king on youtube and yeah
that's about it
hello my name is lee i am a carpenter i
do only fans i a little bit of modeling
and soon starting a podcast so stay
tuned i'm 30 years old and single
wait you're a carpenter and you do only
fans
i don't think anyone wants to talk about
carpentry here really that's the part i
was interested in
whatever you want and fans also okay
well we'll definitely get into that
later
so um today's topic is are modern women
self-destructive so
the reason being is we often talk about
how men have a video game addiction and
a corn addiction that's common right but
what we don't talk about is women's
addiction to social media
so
um there's a study saying girls
much higher rate of depression than boys
is closely linked to the greater time
they spend on social media and online
bullying and poor sleep are the main
culture culprits for their low mood new
research reveals
so
my question is do you guys think
that social media is destructive to
modern women and relationships in 2022
yes so
so go around everyone say so you could
start
yes but i don't necessarily believe it's
uh exclusive to women alone i think the
impacts well i know the impacts that it
has on women are men that is for both of
both sexes just perhaps slightly
differently in terms of the impacts that
it has on them
in terms of women they're able to get
what they want the most which is
attention
from social media with great ease you
know
and in terms of the guys it acts as a
sedation a drug of sorts
that pacifies them and takes that
robs them of that urge that sort of umph
to want to get things done because i can
just open up my instagram see a nice red
little notification bell open up my dms
and i'll get that dopamine kick which
typically before you would have had to
actually do something meaningful to have
gotten that dopamine kick so i don't
think it's just women that are affected
by it but for sure women are affected by
it no doubt
i very much agree with everything you
just said um so i think women would
probably be more affected by it just
because um of you know our natural
want to always compare ourselves and
that's something that's you know really
sort of sort of frustrating so i think
it can be detrimental because
um
there's a lot of comparison um there's a
lot of looking at other women and
they've got filters they've got editing
and there's a lot of comparing yourself
to that there's also the validation
point which is very good i do feel like
social media is a very egotistical place
i feel like um i don't i've said this
before but i feel like when you go and
post sexy pictures on social media it is
for validation because if you if you was
truly empowered and happy with yourself
all you have to do is look in the mirror
i think it's yeah so i do think it's
dangerous as i work with young people so
i see the effects it does have on young
women specifically um and i think it's
just detrimental um in general so that's
just my little take on it
i definitely agree that um social media
addiction for women is a big issue
um
so
for me it's definitely an issue i'm on
social media literally 24 7
and
you mentioned poor sleep definitely due
to that um but yeah i think
one thing we haven't spoken about yet is
the fact that
um
social media for women widens the dating
pool massively so like
you basically have like
a whole range of people to choose from
now and it's like the paradox of choice
it's like you have so much choice to the
point where you don't even know
what is good and what isn't anymore and
it's like things are very easy to fake
on social media
things like men can pretend to be things
they're not so
it's really interesting to see the
effects that it's had on our day in life
i think
okay cool like so with the social media
thing and relationships here it messes
it up because just like um my
you know my guest here was saying yeah
um it widens the dating pool like you
could be going out with a girl in london
and drake can hit up your girl like any
guy in the world can help your girl and
like it makes it a thing of like the
competition like raising the game and
like you know if you're an average guy
you know you've got all this talk about
high value man high value man because a
lot of these girls are looking at like
10 guys one percent guys on instagram
who are flossing on boats and that and
then they're expecting well yeah i
should have that life as well then
obviously the other thing of like girls
looking at other girls comparing
themselves you know you've got the whole
epidemic of bbos and surgeries and stuff
like that because girl's scene i've got
oh my god i've got to get my body like
that as well do you get what i'm saying
so it kind of just messes it up um and
yeah just the fact of like you know you
can have a you can literally have an
affair in your phone like no one will
know you get them saying like messages
disappear like snapchat and all that
kind of stuff so
like it kind of it kind of messes up the
whole relationship thing and yeah people
don't really trust each other anymore
john i mean
yeah i agree to what everyone is saying
uh what i've noticed with myself and
others i guess is that
our confidence we're not nearly as
confident because now
we don't approach people we don't
approach women men don't approach women
women don't approach men
but also
i would rather hit on someone on
instagram
rather than
approach them because
i know that i'm gonna get
if i get a reject it's going to be like
a lot more
difficult to recover when i'm you know
trying to approach someone outside in
public whereas it's a lot easier on
instagram because you just get rejected
you just move on there's no one there to
witness that you're not going to be
embarrassed about it um
yeah
so i'm curious what um how has only fans
affected your relationships
um
okay well i don't really know yet
because i've only been doing this for
four months uh
i i don't know if it has affected my
relationships
um there was a girl that was kind of
into and we stopped talking because i am
assuming that
i might be completely wrong maybe it was
not the reason but i think
as soon as she saw that i was doing only
fast she's kind of like yeah it's not my
thing which is fair i don't blame anyone
if they don't want to
you know if it's not your thing i
totally get it but lee you mentioned
something just now you said that you'd
prefer to go if you're going to approach
a woman you'd prefer to go through the
instagram instagram route as opposed to
in real life but you've got to have a
certain level of confidence to do what
it is that you do
so
like how did how did these two things
play out on the one hand scared of
rejection from a woman or i'm not scared
but you know it makes you anxious at
least of being rejected online but then
on the other hand
you're laying down the gal online real
way again
no look it's not for me personally i'm
not
it doesn't affect me it doesn't affect
my confidence to approach someone in
public as much as other people that i've
seen
uh but it's just easier you know it's
just it's so much easier because i know
i kind of know what i'm getting if i'm
going to dm some girl i know what she
looks like
you know usually
do you know what she looks like okay
sure there's a show called catfish yeah
don't be don't catch yourself sure sure
there's these things i can find out
about her
a lot easier on instagram or social
media than
in public and of course look i do prefer
public i i like that but it just makes
it so much easier to approach someone
online and that sucks i don't like it
but i think that's why people do it and
that's why they go on tinder it's just
so much you just sit there you can go to
the bathroom and just find a date in
like a few minutes basically you know
what i mean how would you feel if your
girlfriend was on early fans like would
that affect your relationship or would
you feel like that's compatible with
what you do
now if i was with someone she wasn't
only fans
uh it wouldn't bother me obviously
because that would be a bit hypocritical
you know what i mean like i'm doing only
fan she's doing only fans i can't be mad
at her
obviously i would not be happy if she
was collaborating with other people i
unless we had a open relationship which
i'm not about but she basically is kind
of collaborating with other people like
even if it's not physical there's still
like
a virtual interaction there
look
i think
i would sit down and have a chat with
her
and listen to what she thinks about it
what she thinks about me doing only fans
and what i think about her doing on fans
then again we can collaborate together
uh
let me ask you a question lee because
you mentioned when when she first when
zucchini first asked you the question
you took a bit of a sigh before you
answered as to whether you would mind if
your girl would do it or not that
indicated to me that your inner alpha is
talking to is like yeah of course i
would mind but because i'm doing it i
don't really have a leg to stand on so
let's reframe it you don't do only fans
your girl wants to do only fans does it
now bother you
you tricked me there
again if she was doing only fans and i
wasn't i would tell her first of all if
i was interested in collaborating with
if i was interested in starting my own
only fans obviously i'll be like okay
with it
now would i
would it bother me if she was only doing
she was doing only fast for herself and
i wasn't
maybe yeah yeah i
at some point actually the
during when i first started only fans i
was supposed to collaborate with this
girl and i went to a twitter and i saw
she was having sex with like
collaborating well not collaborating
with a lot of guys sometimes like two
three together i'm like if
that girl i would not date and it is a
bit hypocritical for me because i am
also doing corn
but
there's like a line i guess there's a
limit where is the line and who draws it
and when did they get drawn two guys are
at the same time i guess
wow that's um so no carpentry questions
like
do you feel like only fans has different
effects for men and for women
just with um the girls you've talked to
doing it versus like the men yeah i
think so well first of all most of my
friends
female friends do only fans
uh i model as well so you know in that
circle you get to
kind of everyone's doing it now honestly
uh
i don't really know i couldn't i
wouldn't be able to tell um i'm having a
little bit of an impostor syndrome
whereas when i talk to my female friends
about it they don't seem to be
empathetic towards their subscribers
again i might be wrong
but i kind of am i feel like a little
bit of empathy and i don't
maybe that's why i have impostor
syndrome you know what i mean
um
imposters imposter syndrome with regards
to what exactly
why are you here what do you what do you
want from me like you know what i mean
like it's
i don't understand why they're there i
guess
does that make sense no
the subscribers i mean oh the why are
they subscribers is it mostly men or
women mostly women but i have some men
as well yeah okay
mostly female subscribers
which surprised me to be honest with you
that surprises me too yeah
i was i was thinking maybe like it would
be mostly guys yeah me too i thought so
and i don't i don't try to target a gay
audience i'm not a bisexual game myself
so i don't target that audience if they
ask me for something that is kind of
towards that i'll be like it's not my
thing
uh yeah mostly female yeah what made you
want to start it like money
okay actually my male friends convinced
me to do which is kind of funny they all
set me down when they're like dude you
need to do only fans i have a bit of
following on instagram and social media
and
i would never recommend to someone that
doesn't to do only fans honestly because
you're not going to make money so i'm
curious why doesn't everyone go around
and say if they would would you date
someone with an only fans
guys and girls both
i mean i i can assume i just thought i
gave you my answer
no
i've actually had someone try to hit on
me that did only fans and i i declined
yeah i wouldn't
hell no
why speak your truth why because like
bro like you're putting yourself out
like you're putting your box on show for
everyone bro
like if you're my girl if you're my girl
i meant to have that private like
connection with you
not like oh yeah like some random like
him him
anyone in here could just like click on
the internet boom boom boom oh yeah
michael king i've seen your girl i've
seen a box like nah bro like no that's
no and then when you have a child as
well it stays on the internet forever
that would be a worry of of mine too so
you could imagine going into school
and like how much you would get ripped
because your mom is on it like do you
know what i mean yeah so that would be a
bit concerning what concerns me is like
only funds is obviously not a forever
thing because eventually you're gonna
get older people are gonna be less
attracted to you and stuff like that and
then when you want to get a job
afterwards like and you have to like i
don't know give a pay slip or something
i don't know and they they realize that
um you've been doing early fans like i
can imagine how that could maybe create
some judgment or stigma or like
in the you could possibly not get the
job or be missed out on promotions i've
heard i know of a girl who she posted a
picture in a really little big black
bikini
and it went round work it went all
around her workplace someone got it off
her facebook and sent it so a year later
she was up for a promotion and one of
the first things that they said was is
this the little black bikini woman and i
weren't obviously saying it was someone
who i won't think but um she didn't get
the job because of that because
you know the thing is is in a corporate
environment if you if that's the thing
you know you're not respected because
you're not respecting yourself in that
manner
um and you know you either earn respect
or you command it you can't just walk
into a place and demand respect because
you're a woman or because you're a man
or vice versa but um yeah i think
there's gonna be facial recognition
software that comes i think that's gonna
be the next thing is like facial
recognition so they can find anything
that's on the internet
and so i'm curious what about do you
worry about that yeah of course all
these things you're talking about i have
thought many times and i still worry
about them to me it's about like
choosing your regrets i'm gonna have
some regrets regardless whether you know
whether i
have only fans or i don't have only fans
because some because only fans gives me
money and that i can invest i can start
my own business potentially or something
if it was very little money i would
never ever do this but i'm doing quite
well and it can go better can i ask you
how much you don't have to say if you
don't want um roughly
i wanted to ask that
um you don't you could if you don't want
to say i can give you like paint it's
like um
i make
suspension
um like a full-time job and a half i
would say like a fairly good in a month
or in a year in a month yeah yeah
monthly i would say like i do is make
make as much as a full-time and a half
job also roughly that's yeah it's good
it's giving a movie right now living a
movie right now movie yeah you're living
a movie bro corn movie yeah exactly
that's what i'm saying i mean to answer
your question pearl you asked me just
now um where would i date and only fans
go i'm a conservative muslim and this is
going to make for a very interesting
discussion yes
we don't even date
period
if i wanted to marry you today i would
go to your father and i'd approach your
father and i'd say to you what's your
dad's name if you don't mind me asking
dan dan i'd say dan i've taken interest
in your daughter i think she's a lovely
girl but i wanted to approach you first
this is the respectful manner i
approached your father dan
and your father he would take that
responsibility of vetting me out you see
he would make his or do he take his due
diligences upon me and then after that
once dan has gotten to know me and has
accustomed himself with me and me and
you have sat down a couple of times
maybe we go for coffee the family don't
always have to be around
after that process it's very swift and
quick at that moment you and your father
dan will decide and you will be like you
say to your dad look i like him or i
don't like him and then after that you'd
have to be like okay we're going to make
this happen or we don't make this happen
and in this way
i don't mess around with dan's daughter
dan's daughter is able to maintain one
of the her most valuable assets which is
her chastity and purity and we're going
to get onto body count today as well
which we're going to talk about right
yeah so this this dating thing is it's
not a thing for us in the first place do
you think it's better that way
100 yeah i think so too
because i think what makes you say that
i think women like
often times were i think men can vet
other men better than women vet men
because like you know we'll be enamored
by like a smooth i mean how many how
many kids how many girls has nick cannon
got pregnant
nine minutes if
i've got the sauce and i know how to
talk to a woman
it's a wrap but that's not gonna work
with big dan yeah yeah see dan's gonna
be like listen big man that's not
working with me you see and then he's
able to
to vet me out for himself and then
ultimately the final decision still
rests with you yeah and lays with you he
can't force you to do it either way or
not
but him being involved in that process
number one helps you to vet him out and
number two it adds a little bit of a
fear factor and that fear factor is if i
mess around with this girl here i'm
gonna have to be held accountable to big
dan
you see whereas when there's no
father figure brother figure uncle
figure in the picture that i know i'm
gonna help be held accountable too
that's easy pickings it's low hanging
fruit and that's the way man yeah but i
almost think that only works if like the
girl is pure because what guy's gonna do
all that for like a girl that's been ran
through oh 100 yeah 100 like what guy's
gonna go meet the dad and like do all
that i think that's the difference like
you mentioned before to your show in
your show
men care about the past when it comes to
women yes
whereas men where women care about the
future it's not
it's a little bit um
it's a bit of a double standard but it's
not i don't think it's as bad for men to
be doing only fans right
yeah you know what i mean i would agree
with that and and this is not me being
funny or anything but we gotta
understand that
first of all
it it's a whole different dynamic even
when you said to me that you did only
fans i didn't have the same reaction
that i think i would have had with a
woman i would have been and and that's
and that's just a natural thing so yeah
i agree um not that i not
not that i can i condone it to be honest
with you i don't believe in i don't
really like sex oops yeah i could say
i don't really i don't i don't condone
it at all um
also from just a spiritual perspective i
just the sharing of your body
continuously with other people um i
believe it's a lot of fun
yeah but to be honest with you yeah fun
but pleasurable but i mean my opinion is
it's not really worth it unless you're
with someone who genuinely cares and
loves about and loves you otherwise it's
just a moment of pleasure no look i
don't like i certainly don't i'm not
that type of person that would be like
no [ __ ] you and i'll do whatever i want
with my body my body my my choice but i
don't i'm not like that at all i
completely understand where people are
coming from when it comes to only fans
and sex work um
yeah yeah it's just your cup of tea
yeah look i'm also in that type of uh
scene like i i play i used to play music
i was in a band i do modeling all my
friends are models all the
probably all the girls i've dated were
models and
it just it makes it a bit easier for me
as well if i was not in that scene i
don't think i would be doing it um
so you don't view sex as sacred
you don't view sex as sacred
yes and no like i'm gonna enjoy in one
night stand and i'm also gonna enjoy
something more intimate i i'm not a big
fan of
of one night stands i'm not and i'm not
a huge fan of collaborating with like
random girls either i would much rather
be in a relationship with do it yeah
do you guys think that social media has
made girls sleep around more
definitely like do you think that's
increased like body counts across the
board one hundred percent yeah yeah it
would have to i mean like the options
are endless with social media like if
you want to seep around you can seep
around as much as you want and already
as a woman like
we are the gatekeepers of sexuality so
it's like that trip will not even trip
would like
just to disproportionate numbers
um
and also it's kind of like
social media has like this culture where
like
women are gratified for that kind of
behavior like if you
if you you know show a lot of skin if
you twerk online
if like everything on social media
revolves around getting laid like most
social media platforms i believe get
are revolved around either having sex or
getting paid in money so
yeah
yeah well and it's whenever men say that
they're repulsed by this it's it's shame
like whenever men have standards they're
shamed for it so whenever they say i
have a i don't want a girl that has her
ass on instagram people say they're that
he's wet slut-shaming yeah and so it's
like there's no accountability for women
because we don't we're not even held
accountable for what we do yeah
so so why would you why would you not
like hypothetically why would you not
sleep around when there's no consequence
is what you think right there's
literally no rules like the way i kind
of see it in our current society there's
no rules for chicks like chicks can just
you know i mean any guy stands out oh i
don't want to date a girl that's got a
high body camera oh you're shaming us
like what do you mean like and then when
you look at in the other side you know
girls have like long laundry lists of
requirements and then you know it's all
good like they say oh i don't want to
date a guy that shoot is like where's
the short shaming yeah
what if they had a short man march like
the same way they had [ __ ]
march no one would kill no
nobody would care but i think the the
biggest problem is that there's actually
no consequences now to having sex like
you can get um contraception you can get
abortions condoms like eradicate
basically most like stis
socially is basically accepted and
normal so there's literally no
consequences for having sex anymore and
i feel like that's what what has made
sex such a
like it the value of sex has decreased
so
yeah we're so desensitized like we see
it everywhere we have access to it
everywhere so yeah and we see women
obviously being sexual
all the time i don't know about you but
i don't really want to see someone
clapping their cheeks when i open my
phone i don't and i don't want to see
you half naked
um yeah and i think it it it's it's so
it's like the wild west out there at the
moment what happened at the beaches too
i'm like when did thongs when did it
become acceptable
in public can we talk about this okay
you know shopping for bikinis
can we talk about that shopping for
bikinis that are not thongs
is so hard like i feel like the whole of
like pretty little thing sheen any like
online retailer has only thongs as
bikinis like finding a full bottom
bikini is so difficult
i feel like these days a lot of times
you you'll notice a lot of girls they
just it's like they basically want to
come out naked as close to naked as
possible like you know i mean like all
you have to do is go instagram explore
page you just see it even just like the
regular girl that's like around the
corner from your house check out her
social media bro like it's mad and then
if you go into clubs raves and that like
goes away and like like dresses with
holes everywhere and gaps in their
clothes everywhere and like nipples all
the time it's mad i don't know so how
can we say women like they get mad about
being sexualized but they come out naked
yeah i was about to mention you can't
that's what gets me because i have again
i have i know a lot of people that do
only fountains they complain about being
objectified
how
that's how you make money what are you
complaining about that's one thing i
never understood i'm very aware that i'm
being objectified i accepted it i'm okay
with it so
women there's some some dissonance going
on here women want to be objectified not
all of us hold on she just doesn't want
to be objectified on its own she wants
to be objectified which is appreciated
for her assets but she also wants to be
appreciated for other elements of her
character and personality that she
brings to the table as well so this
business of women don't want to be
objectified i had a video about this
just the other day that's all nonsense
of course you want to be objectified you
want your husband or your boyfriend to
look you and be like
never compliment you you spent two hours
doing your makeup you're looking sharp
you're looking beautiful yeah the curves
and everything but it's being
objectified of course you're saying by
your husband
your backside looks great and your
breasts look amazing and your eyes look
beautiful yeah i've been able to
objectification no no no okay so the
backside it looks great like do you know
what i mean but your man can compliment
you without objectifying you that's the
same thing no i don't think compliments
are actually
yeah
what's that what's the difference like i
mean i feel like being objectified is
obviously
okay yes i feel like being objectified
is when you are
basically take i don't know how to work
i think yeah i think being objectified
is literally being only looked at
for
having sex with
yeah yeah yeah yeah hence hence why i
said this if he's married to you or
dating you isn't it kind of clear though
yeah obviously obviously but i'm saying
that's the only reason why he's looking
at you yes not with all of the other
stuff so say i'm saying like this is
kind of confusing to men though because
it's like where's the line between
objectifying you and a compliment i
think there needs to be like a good
balance uh you wanna
see
your wife or girlfriend or whatever as a
bit of a hoe
in bed because
if she's not you're not going to be
attracted to her
but also you want to respect her of
course there's like a scene in in sex in
the city that kind of blew my mind uh
what's that innocent one the uh
oh
i don't know her name the vanilla
charlotte oh charlotte yeah
so there's a scene in that series i
don't even know why i just remember this
where
her husband could not get it up because
she wanted her to be like this very
innocent vanilla person not she wanted
to be like that she wanted to be this
innocent vanilla person and not even
have sex with him and when she tried to
have sex with him he couldn't get it up
because you could not see her as this
slurry sort of
yeah but you can command your sexual
energy and you can like be able to be
sexy and not [ __ ] there's a difference
between a health healthy sexual energy
and you know being sexy and classy and
being sexy and slightly there's two
different ways that you can take it it's
just depending on how you project how
you can yeah i think we're talking about
the same thing when i say [ __ ] i don't
mean like go out and just
be naked and stuff i mean like for you
for your husband be a little bit you
know yeah i agree with that i think
that's important i think i think having
a really healthy
um spicy sexual relationship and
maintaining that throughout your
relationship is very important but only
for that person yeah so you know what i
mean like there's certain outfits that i
would wear in the house with my
boyfriend and that i am not going to
walk out on the road and wear
it's just simple can you say that women
don't want to be objectified when we
wear makeup
and technically makeup um like the
reason we wear red lipsticks is because
during sex like your lips get red and
same with the blushing of the cheeks
yeah so there's like a biological reason
why women wear makeup and it's to
indicate signs of fertility and sex
so can we say that we don't want to be
objectified when we wear makeup i mean
there is like this underlying power i
guess you could say with like being a
woman and being seen like
in a sexual way and i feel like nowadays
especially women are like capitalizing
the most like
that they can
into having like
into being viewed as a sexual
person or object or whatever um so yeah
i feel like
i guess i guess we do do that i thought
just as sexy without makeup on the only
time i ever put makeup on is when i come
to things like this otherwise the
majority of the time wow
um just to be a bit more where is it
coming from here um yeah so sometimes
i'll put it on just to be a bit more
presentable um i think but the majority
of the time i don't it just it just
depends sometimes i could shop without
it a lot of the time when i go to when i
go to work with my young girls in the
school when i do youth work i don't wear
any makeup because for me it's really
important that when i shop for them i
show up how i am sometimes i choose to
wear makeup sometimes i like putting it
on and you know
do you wear makeup at home on your own
let's say you're wearing no so you don't
wear makeup at home so what's the
difference then between waking up at
home let's pretend we're back in
lockdown covered right and then at work
what's the motivating or driving force i
don't always wear it to work if i can be
bothered you don't wear no makeup
majority of this yeah i've uh often i
will wear no and in a lot of my videos
you'll see that i post online i'm not
wearing any makeup at all
um i only wear makeup when i decide to
wear it sometimes when i can be i'll be
honest when i can be bothered because it
takes it takes a bit to put it on even
now i'm sweating thinking oh just going
to
melt up but with my boyfriend i feel
very comfortable without any makeup
nothing at all can i ask you a question
so like you're saying
um you have the same level of confidence
with it without makeup yeah i could if
you pass me a baby wipe i'll take this
off now guys it's really not that deep
do you know what i mean is i
i just i disagree i feel like i feel
like you wouldn't wear it that yeah
yeah like like
i mean
i mean i think like i'm more confident i
don't like wearing a lot of makeup but
just like a little makeup i'm more
confident in yeah i mean no no i love
looking good i'm not gonna lie honestly
i will sit there and beat my face for as
long as it takes i love the process
i love i love it so yeah would you say
that you're more confident when you've
got makeup on yeah definitely see that's
the truth right there yeah look i think
it's about yeah you feel good when it's
just when you put effort into your
appearance like obviously if you've put
effort into how you look you're going to
feel more confident because you've
basically made yourself look
like better like why wouldn't i object
better
see my imagination
no but you see my boyfriend when he sees
me in my natural state he prefers it i
feel like you're natural i put again
every woman is different in it every
every woman is different but me
personally i feel just as sexy without
makeup than i do with it do you know
what i mean look i work out michael
works healthy i'm assuming lee works out
as well why do i work out i don't
i work out because i want i like looking
nice okay i want to be healthy and all
the rest of it but the truth is i'm vain
i like to look nice why do you want to
look nice you know what i mean because i
want to be appreciated for how i look
exactly that's a form of objectification
that's okay and the thing is as a man
the thing is as a man
women are they will she'll appreciate my
wife will appreciate how i look but
she's looking at other things that i
need to bring to the table as well yeah
provision protection provision all these
other things whereas with a woman we're
looking at her and we're thinking
you know something i tell my girl
sometimes i say to them you know when
you don't look nice i can't be nice to
you
i find it hard to be nice to you same
with my wife well my wife hamdullah she
always looks nice but if she let's say
your wife looks good without makeup she
looks better with makeup oh okay of
course is this
what i mean what do you got it for me
you get treated better in society when
you look good so i said just now when
you look nice i can be nicer to you
especially when dealing with women yeah
because it's a different energy when i'm
dealing with a woman than when i'm
dealing with a man you see i'm not
expecting him to i have a different set
of expectations from a man than when i
do with a woman i was watching a movie
last night with mike with my wife and it
actually it wasn't a movie it was a
drama program and the woman was uh she
was like the boss [ __ ] archetype right
and she was being extremely assertive
and you know boss [ __ ] what devil
wears product it wasn't it was it was
actually selling sunsets or some drama
real estate program
and i was like i said this is so funny i
can't even take her seriously it's like
she's a pretty woman but she's trying to
assert herself like a man and it's just
all coming off wrong you see women do
have power but it's not in
uh
conducting themselves in a masculine
fashion to me it just looks funny it's
like well i can't take you seriously you
know but women do have a power and
that's in their feminine charm but since
time immemorial women have had this
power over men men have started wars for
beautiful women
but then i don't understand that's when
the beauty goes
that's an excellent question
shout out to abba american because he
was your face changes
okay i know you just got here i didn't
catch your name sorry what's your name
rosman yeah excellent question as you
age the beauty that you had when you
were younger is very different to the
beauty that you have when you're 50 60.
will you not be able to
be nice very good question excellent
question shout out to american make sure
you guys have sub this channel
he said something to me once he's a
youtuber as well and when he said it i
was like man this guy's right
i first got married when i was 16 we can
get to that afterwards yeah voluntarily
married i didn't it wasn't an arranged
thing
when you marry a woman or when you get
into a relationship with a mum with a
woman
she freezes in that moment in time in
your mind
from the point that you meet her for as
long as you spend with each other for as
many years as you spend with each other
if i meet her at 16 as was the case when
i was 16 she just stays looking like
that
if i met her at 25 because i've had
three wives all together at one point
she's
she stayed now obviously she ages and
she gets older and you can't look past
that but
that initial image that you see in your
mind is captured there
and i think that's the
and so that's what we're saying right
and that's what she was saying once the
beauty
the physical beauty things what you're
falling in love with is the soul so do
you not think that's what it is because
that's gone
i mean look ultimately
she's always gonna have to keep on top
of her appearance yeah i agree with you
what if she gained a hundred pounds
she's still friends no no no no that's
all wrong that's all wrong yeah she has
to keep on top of her appearance to the
best of her ability yeah but what i'm
what i'm also saying is is you can still
keep on the top of you can still keep on
top of your appearance and not put a bit
of makeup on your face really it can ask
you a question you mentioned the saw and
all that stuff what would happen if you
sorry the what you mentioned they saw
you you fall in love with this saw so
yeah
what would happen if your boyfriend or
her husband went broke
um what do you mean
when bro just broke
lazy broke just depressed
you didn't know if he was gonna get a
job or not okay fired
um i do you know what it's difficult for
me to answer because i can't ever see a
man that i would be with
having that mentality if my house if my
if my partner
um lost his business tomorrow i would
stay with him because i love him and i
make a lot of money anyway so um
if you became a bum you'd be gone
if you became a yeah if you became a
farmer that's not what we said so let's
just be really clear and concise right
because what i said is i would never be
with a man yeah that would that's what
you said that's not what he asked yeah
yeah so he asked you the question if he
became a bum tomorrow would you stay or
would you go see if i don't if he would
i know but when you say a palm what do
you mean someone so when you say if
tomorrow my mom had a complete
personality transplant it wasn't him who
he was anymore and then all of a sudden
went from a really ambitious go-getting
inspiring soulful man to completely not
that would i leave probably i don't know
but that would be not who i fell in love
with it would have to have work but the
thing is is you can't just give up on a
relationship because you hit bad times
you need to fall in love with people's
roots not just their flowers for how
long so for help
feel good disney stuff bro
look look the reality is yeah listen
serious things
so my bad the reality is yeah like women
operate by hypergamy women operate by
looking up to a guy if you're with a guy
yeah and now he's beneath you you're
supporting him you're not going to
respect him no more see he's going to be
the bee in the house oh you're saying
like you're feeding him you're putting a
roof over his head like he can't do
nothing for you except give you d
yeah right and i'll probably be mediocre
as well so
like bro like
you're gonna be like let me get me who's
already talking about social media what
you're gonna do is go on instagram see
right this guy's on a boat right see now
i don't like it no because you can't no
you can't make that assumption you know
you can tell because you're not
answering this yeah yeah i'm not saying
i'm not wrong right but what i'm saying
is me i'm not saying in general in it
what i'm saying is i'm giving my
personal opinion so you guys are saying
if he like completely is not who i fell
in love with do you know what i mean
would it change i mean yeah but then
you'd have to work on that relationship
i wouldn't i can't just say now if
certain things happened that i would
leave no one says
no one's saying you leave the next day
but
you your respect level for him will
start to decrease
if he's not if he's not out there like
doing if he's if he's not building on
his life if he's not living his purpose
if he's not do yeah of course
of course in that respect but what and
let me just say this one thing anyone
can fall off yeah because you keep
saying oh he changes our personal blood
anyone can fall off bro yeah but that's
the point that but that's the point of
falling in love with someone's roots
there are going to be times in your life
if you're in a long-committed
relationship right that your partner
goes up and they go down now if you
leave them at that like do you know what
i mean just at the first sight of like
you know the ship sinking then then you
know that then why were you really with
them in the first place because they
were winning that's why you no but
that's not why you should are you are
you going
disney stuff again are you gonna get are
you gonna get with an ambitious post
postal worker postman
[Laughter]
i mean
it's it's not working
no probably not yeah and that's and
they're just asking you to be like
honest yeah and so but when you dance
around the question and kind of don't
answer the question that he asked and
say well my my partner
like it comes across as not honest okay
i get that but the thing is is i again
you think very differently to a lot of
people right so you have a lot your
opinion is very different to a lot of
women would you would you agree with me
it depends on what
most women most women look for ambition
that's something i look forward to in
work ethic so that's pretty similar yeah
so all i'm saying is for me personally
would i be so quick to drop my man if he
went broke i wouldn't be quick would it
be an ongoing problem could i have the
possibility of leaving him maybe but i
can't i couldn't remember but the point
is like he only has so long yeah like
you're not going to stay for five years
of him doing nothing let me give him and
i don't i wouldn't fault him i wouldn't
fall too far
i wouldn't i wouldn't fault a dude who
who left because his his wife gained a
hundred pounds for five years and like
he'd give her time to work it off i
think what i was taking with with the
question is what it sounded like to me
is if your man has no money then would
you leave in it so that was the basis
it's not not the first day or the first
month even obviously like yeah you would
stick around yeah let me give you a
different response because
you want to see what's going to happen
yeah lydia let me give you a it's lydia
right yes yeah let me give you a
different perspective because i am not
i don't completely
i'm not completely against women who
jump ship the moment they see it sinking
let me tell you why men do it as well
shall i tell you when a man does it
if you're working for a company you're
working for this job you're working for
some big blue chip corporation okay and
then you find out you hear in the
whispering in the corridors that crap
this company's got six months left and
then they run out of that that's it yeah
are you going to be there like a loyal
employee no you would like a bitter
company
but this here's the point now
the the point i'm trying to make to you
is as an employee you are in a
subordinate position
okay the one who is who has that level
of leverage over you is your employer
and you as an employee are in a
subordinate position
in a relationship well maybe not today
but typically in a relationship um the
the wife is in a subordinate position to
a man this is not by the way a bad thing
there has to be a leader you can't have
two ceos two generals two presidents
right
she's in a subordinate position to him
as in the relationship which means what
she's in a vulnerable position just as
you as an employee or in a vulnerable
position if you see your your company
going out of business you are going to
start
applying for jobs elsewhere now
relationships are much more complicated
than this there is love there is
children and so on and i would expect
a good decent respectable woman to stick
by her decent respectable man if he's a
decent respectable man
you have to ride it through that storm
and hopefully he'll pick himself up but
just to shine a different perspective
like because i know a lot of men get
really triggered by this but when we
shine on this different light this
employer employee sort of analogy we can
kind of understand
if a woman is hypergamous as michael
just pointed out which she is she's
looking for her employer for want of a
better word all right as soon as the
ship starts sinking i understand why
women start thinking a bit sideways i
don't agree with it once they jump ship
if he's doing his best as a man but i
get it
hmm i think i just need to admit and
accept that a relationship there's no
unconditional love a relationship is a
business
and i know we want to believe in this
disney crap you mentioned before we want
to do that and that sounds lovely but
it's not it's a it's a deal it's a deal
for unrealistic bars man
yeah i mean watching cinderella sleeping
beauty nah bro you're gonna get messed
up
have you ever noticed how all the movies
that do well are like a very attractive
man that dates an average looking girl
so for example fifty shades of grey
she's like a six he's like a nine yeah
and it's like the same dynamic i think
the corn for women you know yeah
because the more cause like the majority
of women can identify with that woman
like oh like i can see myself in that
woman and then i can imagine i'll get my
prince charming no you won't breath
no i don't believe in the fairy tale
paradox either like like i don't i don't
believe in that either i just feel like
you know i just feel like it should you
shouldn't be with a man just because of
what he can provide you and i understand
that the basic dynamics is what you said
i i get that i pers i get that and i'm
not saying
i'm just saying me personally i just
think that feeling
but there's a difference okay
i understand what you're saying you're
saying there's a difference between
money and ambition and like like yeah
because roller tomassio always says
there's a different like girls would
rather get with the guy that got the
money lost the money and then got it
again rather than the guy that just won
the lottery because there's a difference
between like a guy that you can depend
on a guy that just got lucky and hit the
jackpot yeah and i think that's what
you're trying to say
there's a great the great saying by
marilyn monroe it's actually a clip you
can find it from one of her movies and
she said
marrying a beautiful woman sorry
marrying a rich man is like marrying a
beautiful woman
he doesn't have to be she doesn't have
to be beautiful but my gosh it helps my
goodness doesn't it my goodness doesn't
it i've seen that clip yeah and i think
that was it again like for me it's it's
more about loving people for who and not
the fairy tale thing either but loving
them for who they are in it so we don't
know women can't women can't love men
for who they are not in the same way men
can love women it's different it's it's
different because because for us there
are requirements for men you just have
to be hot and there
sorry
for women it's like he has to be this
tall he has to make this much money and
maybe it's not money but he has to have
a certain level of drive for you to be
attracted to him women's love is
conditional men's isn't it yeah mine is
spirit as well i i connect a lot by a
spirit to be honest with you and morals
and values shared values um what does
that even mean spirit so like it's sort
of like
it's hard it's hard to sort of like
describe as well to be honest with you
but
um so what device yeah it's it's the
vibe it's just sort of like spiritual
alignment like okay you think that
subconsciously that also
the vibe you're talking about
subconsciously it's something that
matters to you as a woman like how do i
explain this
like it's like a primal thing i can't i
don't understand what you mean yeah i
think we have we have like intuition as
women and like i think that's pretty
undeniable but you know when you meet a
guy maybe it's like something chemical
going on or whatever it might be but i
can look at a man and just be like
attracted to
like his personal energy yeah his energy
that gets you in trouble and how is that
that's right that's right
that's why men vet other men better than
women do yeah
that's what my man was saying over in
the corner about like he has to go to
the girl's dad because if you rely on
your own intuition i mean there's a lot
of single mothers running around
and that's the thing with artists like
you think it's just because he's good at
playing guitar for example but it's not
it's because he
is creative and creative means
you know provider usually peop you know
women think like oh i like it because
you're a musician it's never as simple
as that i think if it's an artsy thing
like that it's more fun because a lot of
times girls work that's fun
but i think it's also the creative part
like the creativity part like you are
creative yeah and i think that's got
something to do with it as well um
because the creativity allows you almost
to be
almost allows you a little bit in touch
with your feminine energy as well
because you know feminine is creativity
well not with you maybe
but even like with art and stuff like
that so yeah well it's like women become
the men they want to marry right
so it's like they're always looking for
when they you ask a girl like what she
wants in a man often she's describing
herself do you know what i when i look
for a man i often describe my father
yeah i found that i feel like yeah i'll
be real um that that is my that has been
my and it's funny because my current
partner does have a lot of similar
traits to my father the way he treats me
the way um he speaks to me the way he
protects me and stuff like that so um
yeah i'm going to take a second to read
super chats um also we have a new guest
on the panel do you want to introduce
yourself
i'm russman you can talk so um bring the
mic a little closer to you i know you
weren't here for instructions yeah there
you go
you i'm russman okay nice to me um i
think i met you i was interviewing you
yeah okay
um okay so super chats vincent dollisale
jr
purple
purple people eater on the couch is
capped she knows that if her man was a
bum she would be
out of there faster than leah thomas
beating all those swimmers and sentients
continuing just as makeup wearing
certain just as
um last week he was doing the dishes
this week he's doing the fries sentience
just as makeup wearing certain
provocative clothing also evokes
attention and validation therefore women
do not dress and wear makeup for
themselves otherwise they should
confidently wear a clothes sack and wear
no makeup
sentients the old excuse of wearing
makeup for themselves is pure rubbish
wearing makeup influences confidence
because of external validation otherwise
women could paint their faces like a
clown and they should get the same
confidence but they don't betty jean
mary this is why women should get with a
man when she's young because she because
only will he appreciate her beauty when
she's 60. the uk economist please oh
i'll ask this question but i'm going to
read the rest of the super chats first
um jg thank you for the super chat bozzy
when a man sees an attractive woman he
can only sexually objectify her he
doesn't know her yet human nature is
primarily sexual for men and women
vincent d'allisal jr the guy who
approached the dad first has it right
that's a necessary thing that many women
choose that women many women don't do
men know how to help choose a lasting
man better alistar horton i would say
the dad's second step is they need the
woman's approval before they even meet
them
bazi the alpha next to pearl
approaching the father for the woman is
correct straight boss move the father
will vet the man better than any woman
ever will doug mpa pearl and king
richie's in the same room i've been
following him for years thank you for
all of your hard work throughout the
years you are one of the unsung heroes
of the manosphere and your time will
come keep it up
dao keep up the great discussions jpt
will you have on southeast
asian and east
asian guests in the future zmj shout out
to king r glad glad to see you making
the rounds bozzi
marriage is a significant risk for men
and is against the male sexual strategy
100 percent supports a woman's sexual
strategy as a result if a woman is not a
virgin she does not qualify for marriage
honest citizen shout out to king r aka
michael king alistar horton most modern
women have a firmer grip on their phones
than they do on reality
monkey you saw the goat king r baozi i
never thought i'd see king ritchie's on
here big up my brother have him on more
jay doe this ish will stop when all dues
man up patriarchy sentience lizzie is
oh wait no that's from the last one okay
let me see let me refresh the page
really quick
um
the
uh matt butcher ladies wear makeup for
themselves to get attention brit cormier
i connect a lot in spirit it's hard to
explain total bs you do not want to put
it into words then when she got caught
then she could because then she could
get called out on it black is panther
women say they love men for who they are
but that's a lie you love a man for the
lies he tells you interpret it as vibes
if a man reveals his true self to you
you leave because you can't handle it
vincent dalsa oh i did that one already
okay
um so
an interesting stats i've been listening
to like man manosphere content the last
couple of months and a crazy stat that i
heard
um
was
what percent chance do you think a
virgin has of a happy marriage
in 10 years if they like follow up with
her in 10 years
they're going to be a higher one but i
don't know like a higher one because
yeah she would have less men to compare
it to yeah so yeah she would have less
men to compare it to so she would be
more satisfied with the one man that she
was with and um i'm not saying that i
can't think but yeah i think a virgin
would be more satisfied um
than a
woman who's had um more sex personally
anyway
i think obviously due to things like
pair bonding and stuff like that it's
definitely going to be higher um
yeah i have nothing else maybe like
60 more okay what do you guys think yeah
65 or so hell yeah because like
obviously if a girl's been throwing a
box around then obviously she's had all
different shapes or sizes all different
kind of takers and all of that
strategies and that rub like and then
she's going to come to one guy and then
going to be like oh yeah let me settle
for this biscuit bro she's gonna be like
brother i've had bigger biscuits and
bread like it's just gonna i think it'll
make it tougher for her to settle she's
what i'm saying like has that ever
happened where you've like hooked up
with a girl or like been seeing a girl
and you can just tell she's too ran
through
because like she's comparing you or
something like that i was with one that
her number was over a hundred oh wow
no only there's nothing no no model
nothing it's just civilian
yeah
very beautiful girl um
personally i just felt like i did not
earn it
uh but i don't know what was it what was
the question again i forgot
um i asked if that's ever um
if you've ever been with a girl and you
could just tell that she was so ran
through that it was almost like she was
comparing you to other guys or something
like that
no i can't recall or i've heard guys say
like her soul is like gone from her eyes
that's one thing i've heard
why are you smiling
nah like no because i feel like a lot of
times if the girl likes you she'll gas
you up either way she'll just lie
okay so you don't think you can tell
like what inside the box you're talking
about no no i'm not just interacting
with the girl oh yeah like usually you
can you can feel like certain like
you can see certain flags like you know
i mean what are the flags
like for instance yeah just the way she
talks like is she just she's very like i
know some people might not agree with
this but if she's like super open and
free and it's like oh and then she'll
tell you like i was seeing this guy and
blah blah blah it's just like because me
i think i've got this skill i make i can
make people feel comfortable with me and
they will usually just start like
basically exposing themselves in it i'm
saying and then like if you've got that
skill it's easy to detect if she's like
ran through in my opinion and then yeah
maybe she didn't like me maybe her
number was actually 200 or something
right it's probably a
um so to answer the question though a
virgin has an eighty percent chance of a
happy marriage after ten years
so if a girl's
like sorry it's interesting why is this
not taught in schools like i feel like
this should be taught from such a young
age
because girl power that's why no but
honestly like i feel like we're getting
lied to so much like
like feminism has literally been
presented to us since such a young age i
think since i first opened my eyes i was
hearing about female empowerment and
this this and that and like at one point
even i like agreed
with it and then it's like
getting older and understanding the
world and understanding everything
around you and understanding you need
men just as equally as much as you need
women in this life
in this life and just like that that you
know your power is elsewhere it's not in
the same things that that it meant
what is the feminist sometimes i find is
they try to portray the masculine like
you said earlier women and men i don't
believe women and men are equal i
believe they're different um i believe
that there's things that men are much
better at and there's things that women
are much better at what i think is the
problem sometimes is we have especially
with the feminist movement anything you
can do i can do better because i'm a
woman and then you know putting
themselves and you know sometimes you
know when women complain about going
into male dominated environments and the
trouble they get i don't quite get it
because for me i feel like it's your
lack of understanding so say for example
if you've got a group of boys right
they'll rip each other in the group chap
if you have a group of girls we can't
see each other and rip each other it's
two completely different dynamics and
sometimes when women go into these
environments they're expecting men to to
treat them the way that other women
would treat them and give them respect
but they haven't earned the respect and
they haven't commanded the respect and
they haven't proactively tried to get
those men to perspective to respect them
you know what i found really interesting
on my only fans i get a lot of uh
women that claim to be feminist and like
quite extreme as well and usually those
moderns are the ones that are asking
nastiest [ __ ]
oh that's there is one question very
degrading stuff no there's one question
that was like why do the why are those
same women that are grossed out by dirty
jokes are the same ones that'll have
guys do that to them in the bedroom oh
yeah
there's something to be this what's that
what's that look
no i don't know hey
what's that what's the look for i don't
get it and certain requests like you get
me like a girl you've been arguing with
all day all day brother the night time
comes about they turned to a different
person about two i can't even say
like mad things no tell us i want to be
in on the secrets
i don't know man like what's the
craziest thing a girls asked
like uh
just like in the shower just oh let me
kneel down and you could just like go to
the toilet one more wow
yeah yeah really yeah yeah i think some
people have people have done that their
people have done that it's so weird as i
was saying like it's a mad world out
here right do you want to know my number
one request on only fans um because i do
a lot of voice notes like fantasies of
voice notes fantasies and the number one
request i get is
grape
oh wow yeah wow yeah
do you know what actually i get that but
that is that is um that's interesting
considering
that
i feel like you're connecting to that
somehow what do you mean like when when
he said that was the number one request
he gets yeah you were like yeah
obviously no i said it's interesting
because so much of feminist movement is
about the violence towards men about
like being scared of men being like
scared that a man will rape up like do
you know what i mean so a big part of it
is like sexual violence and that's why
that's why it's surprised like july
because i was just like oh you know what
you know what show girls love that
freaking
oh my god this just made a lot of sense
that freaking um
the one the handmaid's tale
girls love that show and that's what
it's about tell me about that the
handmaid's tale is basically like
the half the population's infertile so
they like take all the fertile girls and
they're like basically the dude's
grapeing them every
oh yeah
yeah to carry their kids
one of the reasons is sorry real quick
one of the reasons why women watch these
shows is because it's the same reason
why they have like obsession with serial
killer shows it's because it's like a
primal thing that that's how they
protect themselves
so it might not just be the fantasy
i mean what's prohibited is desired and
the more you try to suppress something
within yourself if we're going to use
the example of feminists
the
the raising the rearing of men in uh
this as dysfunctional women as camille
paglia puts it that men are raised today
to be dysfunctional girls right so the
more you try and shout and scream
against something it has a reverse
impact on you the more you actually
secretly desire it and crave it so
there's something to be said about not
being too overbearing on yourself with
regards to things you want to stay away
from because the strange irony is the
more you you force yourself away from it
or you make a big deal out of it the
more you actually want to go towards it
can i ask you something so you really
want to be a whale
you can ask a person you don't have to
answer
you're quite religious
yeah do you ever get that get what like
if it's something like forbidden do you
ever
want the forbidden fruit excellent
question what's prohibited is desired so
okay as a muslim man
i cannot have sexual intercourse with a
woman outside of marriage outside of
holy matrimony would i like to do that
of course i would if i said if i said to
you oh no man i don't like the idea of
being able to sleep with an unlimited
number of women without any
entanglements and any commitments
nonsense of course i would like to you
see but what i'm trying to say is like
to what degree has it affected you
especially because men in general of
course would like to have sex with other
women but to you might be like a little
bit
more intense the feeling no well because
i'm married so i have that outlet and as
a muslim man i can have up to four wives
as well i had three wives at one point
oh yeah i wanted to ask you that yeah so
you know let's shock the audience i've
got eight children i had three wives at
one point when i was 27. i got married
when i was 16. two eyes when i was 25
three wise when i was 27
and eight kids by 30 something 32 or 31
i can't remember do you not have three
anymore uh no so the first two we went
our separate ways now i have one wife i
could get married again if i wanted to
but i'll be if i'm to be perfectly
honest with you i wasted a lot of time
in my 20s like having wives on rotation
i can't even handle one you handle yeah
it's all long like that's it that's it
it's interesting because i'll tell my
dad things about the red pills he's like
what is red pill and like the one thing
because my dad's the top one percent of
earners and so everyone the red pill is
like he's cheating he has all these side
chicks
and uh so i'm like dad where are your
side chicks like what's what's going on
and then he's like he he always says um
let's try let's have these guys try one
wife before they deal with three yeah
like that's too many problems if we all
talk about this is a great discussion
because
one of the major gripes that i have with
the red pill and the red pool has been
extremely beneficial in
enhancing my knowledge with regards to
intersexual relationship dynamics but
one of my major gripes is that on the
one hand
a lot of red pillars will speak quite
vehemently against women with high body
counts but then on the other hand we
don't mind giving men top caliber top
caliber men top 10 1 men a free pass to
sleep with women indiscriminately as a
reward for them having reached the upper
echelon of
earnest basically and this is why islam
comes and it fetters this is pelogeny
basically it fetters a man it says it's
okay you can have multiple women if
you're able to take care of them okay so
there are prerequisites you're able to
house them and take care of them and so
on and you can have up to four you can
have four women no problem but anything
above and beyond that that's prohibited
and this is where men are fettered on
the one hand we are given that outlet to
be able to express our politicians
nature if you can if you can handle it
right but on the other hand it's not a
free-for-all i can't just sleep and
think of the hypocrisy as like oh we're
slamming women with 100 body counts but
then it's okay for a man to sleep
indiscriminately with women i mean i
think it's just more like they made
their bed lie in it like i mean
if these if these hoes that's what they
want to do like half the time it's the
hoes chasing after these guys it's not
even it's not even vice versa
it's like some of these guys open their
dms and it's like
like because my ex-boyfriend was bigger
on social media and so i would see some
of the dm's girls would send him it
would just be like tit pics and [ __ ]
like that just off the bat yeah would
you guys would you ladies do that would
you
no
that's like
um would you if your man was making like
very good money
like really good
and he told like okay i wanna cheat not
cheap not even
just sex with other women what you're
doing
like good money
like he's very comfortable you very well
he's looking after you looking after you
very sick how old am i
no
i feel like at 45 i'd be like you know
what at this point what am i gonna do
right right now right now right you're
married you've been you're in love do i
wait do i have a kid
yes if i had a kid i'd be so irritated
but like you didn't tell me this before
i had the child
um if i if i had a kid i'd stay cause
it's just not about you anymore but i
would leave if i didn't have a kid
because in my head like
i don't know i just i'm big on family
and i think it was really good growing
up that i my parents just were like they
only have dated each other like they're
the only significant other both of them
have had and i think that's just like
better
yeah i don't i don't think i can handle
um cheating in a relationship
um so i definitely leave but as you said
like once you have children like
what are you treating what does chi mean
to you to keno
she is
cheating means sleeping with someone so
if he was just flirting texting maybe
going on dates spending money on her is
that okay
that's not cheating but it's not okay no
it's not so where do you draw the line
where do you say all right how about
something why why
i find that a bit repulsive that like
why are you spending money on a random
girl like that's a bit
like it's more emotional i think that
might hurt a little bit more yeah i was
gonna ask would you rather him take a
girl on a nice date send like spend
money on her or screw a random hoe
no but do you know where is that
is affiliate but then i will have to
leave after as well because if that
happens you know what i mean like i feel
like i feel like sex holds like a
certain like i don't want to be like the
wishy-wish was she spiritual people but
like i do feel like things like transfer
through yourself energy exchange yeah i
i just believe in that and i feel like
if you're if you're sleeping with other
people and you're sleeping with me i
just feel like i'm now getting excited i
don't know who's like
how do you guys do you guys feel like
it's an unfair deal for men um it's like
assuming like no one's a virgin here
so it's like it's almost like like you
almost cheat on him before because you
have sex with like you've had sex with
someone else
where like before like the guy would get
a virgin out of the deal but now
it's like and like in exchange for that
he would give monogamy but it's almost
like you cheat on him before and
sometimes you can come in with a kid
um interesting i see why you're coming
here
i'm not like advocating for this but i
i've heard guys make this argument and
it makes sense to like some extent but
then but then i i completely agree if
that's like what you need out of a
partner and you need a person who's a
virgin absolutely but like just choose a
virgin like yeah we're defining virgins
what
this is where like women just think it's
very easy because your like um angle of
dating is like it's like working it
she's not saying for the typical guy
it's hard that's just just to get a
girlfriend that's not easy bruh so
you're too i'll just get a virgin
i i know a couple i'll set you guys up
i don't know i feel like maybe you're
doing the haystack business maybe like
in my culture i just feel like that's
kind of like the rule like if if i was
to go back home now like most women are
probably like preserving themselves to
marry where are you from morocco okay
that so is that that's common in the
culture there yeah like like but this
conversation centered around the west it
has to be clear
yeah
yeah
so here i mean i mean
i was going to say the stat that i was
going to say if you slept with five or
more people your chance of a happy
marriage after 10 years goes down to 30
and the crazy thing is i think most guys
pray for a girl with five or less bodies
damn in the west she said damn
yeah
no i mean like
because i know damn well like the
average woman in the west has way more
than five bodies like oh yeah yeah
and that's what i'm saying like so it's
almost
like guys are coming in thinking they're
getting i mean i don't think most guys
expect virgins but they're you know
thinking maybe single digits and then
you know they're talking to girls that
have slept with like 100 200 guys you
know what though what i noticed is in in
your show before
there were so many guys that kept saying
no i wouldn't and no offense to you
gentlemen and to the other gentlemen as
well
they kept saying no if i if she slept
with that many people i wouldn't go i'm
gonna do that even nine at 10 came up to
you
really and she told you like i slept or
i had only fans or whatever before
but i slept with like a lot of people
like 50 100 200 i'm cool now
i really like your peasant ass for some
reason
would you go for it issues are nine
that's like a night like a problem no
brethren she's not online anymore she's
not a nine bro how could you be a knight
yeah
what is it she's a nine she's a nine
that everybody's had some questions so
question what is the nine that has 50
bodies what does she become
she's
invisible
i don't know if i believe that i think
we cancel red flags sometimes
i feel like they would they would sleep
with her but they just wouldn't pursue
anything no no no no get me wrong she'll
be on rotation yeah yeah correct
100 correct and she has experience also
but i don't think so i think we cancel
red flags both men and women yeah you're
talking to simpson
you're walking down the road you're
walking down the road even then you're
bumping into like you get me x-men x-men
like fling like you get me dead
high-five in new york
that's our girl bro i'm not talking
about you
guys maybe not you maybe you have
options i like to think i have options i
wouldn't go for it
i understand what you're saying
a lot of men cap i'm saying that
and i would say i actually okay to some
extent i do agree where there's guys i
know on public platforms have said one
thing and i know the girl they're dating
and i know that's not the case
so some dudes do cap i will give you i
will give you that yeah kanye west for
god's sake yeah and i i don't know i
don't think only fans because i think i
think i think only fans is the extreme
right i think most guys aren't going to
date a girl with only fans but there are
guys where like they've said a number on
a show or like and i know who they're
dating and i'm like that's but the thing
is though you gotta remember the
majority of guys are simps you don't say
the majority of guys are sims and like
the most i think the majority of guys
out there because you're thinking you're
probably thinking from your point of
view that like you get me i've got i can
do this i can do that but the average
guy out there is not you the average
guy's not me or the other guest like
jesus i'm saying that are on this panel
right now yeah i'm saying those guys
would also say no i will not date
i don't know i don't know so i have she
will have no shortage of suitors we've
seen it so many times with like proper
high valued men as well like look at
kanye west like and i know it's like an
exception with him but it's not really
so many rich men attractive rich men
have dated like porn stars yeah well i
will say i do think on some level you
attract people who you're like
like you kind of you attract people like
yourself so if you are something you
tend to attract it yeah and kanye west
like what was he he he dated amber rose
too
it's like he's he's been he's been wife
and hoes this is like yeah that's that's
him that's his style like you know like
i just feel like this year
okay kanye west for instance yeah he's
probably got in his phone book people
who have slept with kim kardashian in
his phone booklet like oh yeah like you
see him at a party yeah what's going on
bro what's going on how's your wife yeah
she's fine yeah i know she's fine bro
that's not my life
entertainment are a bad example because
even if you look at athletes um most
athletes after 30 they go broke for a
reason they can't manage their money so
people that are given the opportunity to
make money without having the proper
growth to manage that money end up
becoming a certain type of man so you
look at musicians for example they
didn't do the necessary work to become a
certain type of man so for them to
accept a woman that's throwaway it kind
of makes sense because they haven't done
the necessary work to become the type of
man that wouldn't accept that type of
behavior that's a very good one and a
lot of them guys them celebrities and
athletes you gotta remember they came
from nothing like she's not saying their
background probably was just normal
average sim and now they've got money oh
boom all these instagram models boom
like yeah i'm gonna wife you that i'm
gonna go out with that enough don't you
think it's a it's a business move as
well like
yeah that getting married to kim
kardashian as kanye west makes sense
from a business perspective like
nah that's a [ __ ] thing
no
it's a business it's a business
definitely
it's a disrespect to me because
obviously if i was in that position
looking at her background whether or not
it's a business move and it is a good
financial business movie don't get me
wrong but i respect myself more to
accept a woman like that to be publicly
my woman that makes no sense to me i
think he he shouldn't have had kids with
her if he had just done a thing where oh
yeah we're together like maybe he's he
should have chopped exactly and then
just stopped but you're going pumping
out kid's brother now she's chopping
young butts yeah now that's your name's
attached
so i have a question for the girls um
this is a super chat from the uk
economist thank you this is going
we got isha camera but we we're missing
a piece so it's next show but we're
saving
you know i actually don't know what
we're saving for next year
yeah rent studio uh maybe remember you
said you want to make a studio i i do
i'm trying to move i'm trying to move
out of this sweaty apartment
okay so why should a man court a woman
who is not a virgin because other men
didn't have to court her in the past to
be intimate for free sorry real quick
what does that mean core that date that
yeah why should a man call a scooby dog
why should a man wait wait i scored
rolled up okay why should a man court a
woman who is not a virgin because other
men didn't have to court her in the past
to be intimate for free
um because
men's dating
world is not very there's nothing a lot
of virgins
yeah how are you gonna find out like how
are you gonna find them
and also when you find them are they
going to be honest are they going to
tell that do you mean a new girl turns
18 every day yes
before they even turn leggings
i mean if he wants it i mean if he wants
a virgin i'm sure he can find one online
like do you know what i mean but like i
don't like i do get it right but it's
just the world we live in if we lived in
a time where everyone was a lot more
you know like um not so freeing with the
but i think it's more of a question as
to
if she gave it up
in the early years for free yeah why is
it why is it necessary for him to call
her now shouldn't he also get access to
it for free um well i mean
why should he automatically get the
access to it for free because everybody
else had it for free so yeah i'm sure
i'm sure not every single person in the
world like do you know i mean yeah yeah
yeah yeah contextual here so like yeah
just man them like that that ran through
her yeah now it comes to be your
opportunity you might just be a
well-rounded guy yeah i had to give an
example a lot of girls do do this like a
girl will see potential and value in you
so she wants to treat you like a proper
guy so i'm gonna withhold sex with you
because i want you to be my man yeah but
imagine i'm thinking bro you took him
him him him her yeah
and now i'm the good guy that's to me
that's almost like a disrespect depends
the type that makes sense yeah it makes
sense i can't i can't answer it you know
what i mean because
[Laughter]
i said maybe you don't qualify
yeah and i'm saying that as an average
like the average man probably doesn't
qualify for what she was on average
but i'm saying like the average man
might not be qualified as to what she
wants from a guy that she would give
access to for free if that makes sense
but then if if sex in this scenario is
the ultimate axis for a man
then
again withholding it from the man that
you lack is also counterintuitive
because sex is the one thing that's
probably most likely to keep him around
if that's the only thing you have to
offer see women control sex but men
control commitment
and that's the balance that i think and
that's why i feel like um as well
obviously we're taught as women to not
give it up too soon do you know what i
mean because if you do then there's a
lack of respect and
obviously other things and then also you
know just get to know someone because
but then again
post nut syndrome 100 you could be
seeing a girl for like three four months
you could be holding out and then you
could think and then that guy can after
sleeping with you just really just
genuinely okay i didn't like her that
much yeah clarity sent me to you yeah so
wait wait see that say that
clarity sent me to church
i just thought i thought disgusting
myself
redefine like men could also redefine
their own standards because i feel like
obviously i hear so much talk about like
oh yeah i don't want to
a woman that this this that but on the
daily basis we see that happen every day
i don't disagree because i always preach
that men need to to learn sexual
discipline personally i took a year out
of sex to learn sexual disciplines i
didn't want to be a dog in every
situation
but i also don't put that responsibility
in all men because again you're just
subscribing to your biological impulses
so it's it's more of a choice monogamy
is a biological strategy of women
scattergun spreading our seeds it's a
biological strategy for men we conform
to your standard so we we sacrifice what
we want to get you so i don't also think
that's fair on men to have to take the
responsibility when again like you're
going to get your biological impulses to
favor yours
but i do me i do think that in today's
society to make things work as best as
they should men need to maintain sexual
discipline it's important to successful
relationships and maintaining yeah
yeah stop stop stop [ __ ] fat chicks
so they lose weight
what's your name brother eddie eddie oh
you're eddie
okay i just feel like this like if the
chick sees you as like a i like to say
tyrone or chad yeah like she will she
will give it up bro even no matter what
if she looks at you as a long term or
short time she will give it up bro like
i'm talking from experience bro like she
will give it up so all of this like oh
i'm just gonna wait that means she don't
really rate you that high that's what i
think
but do you think that comes maybe from
like sexual um
like her not being sexually disciplined
as well comes from steve harvey
steve harvey's telling girls to wait 90
days yeah that way you know
would you would you say that you're the
same would you give it up for a girl you
find very attractive
well
the problem is is when women have sex
with men okay it's very different as in
we let off the um there is a bonding
hormone
yes yeah and that's it and it's the same
chemical that's let off when we
breastfeed right so the issue is is with
men don't have that right so the issue
is is with as a woman if you sleep with
a man obviously too you're gonna start
to form an attachment now if you haven't
built any foundation before that or got
to know them or built any type of
friendship then when that man decides to
do you know what i mean because then
you're going to feel a lot more hurt
you're going to feel like you're
betrayed you're going to feel that's the
end but you shouldn't you shouldn't but
yeah and i agree with you but i think
like
the problem is
guys get frustrated because they know
you've given it up for a different guy
earlier so when you're saying oh you
have to wait three months and you're 30.
yeah he's like and every guy is you're
like has every guy done that for the
last 10 years
to be fair i've never said to like i've
never given a guy a time period i've
just gone with it and to see how it fit
but obviously in my head i'm like okay i
want to get to know this man first but i
don't have a set time period in my head
i sort of feel like after speaking to
them for like i thought so it will come
at that do you know what i mean i don't
know why but i might just begin be
speaking for myself i when i really like
a girl i want to make it wait
and i don't think every guy is like that
yeah i don't know why you're good dude
man
spice it up
bro the role model bro
i think what you're saying is is right
but the only difference is that with the
way women conduct themselves now i don't
i almost don't think it's necessary to
have to do that i think no it's not i i
maybe it's like a
i don't know like
it just spice up spices things up for me
let me ask you a question bro yeah do
you think that's because
you're scared that if she get because
you like her and you're scared that if
she gives it up quickly you'll be like
oh my she's just like the rest of them
could be maybe that's one of the reasons
i think i just
that's dangerous because you could be
like oh yeah i'm not gonna give it to
her but then like brother like she is
the type to be on the first place
now you're making her into some princess
that she's not
yeah maybe maybe that is the reason i
haven't really thought about why but
also i just
don't you ever feel like you know
you build
anticipation when you do that and it
yeah yeah right you're right
yeah but i'm not the one after one date
bro no no
there's a common theme that is that i've
noticed in this conversation and that is
that this most of this conversation has
revolved around
women giving up sex at different time
intervals early mid late and so on and
we can see that the denigration of
society really revolves around
promiscuous sex
and this is once again again i'm a
muslim islam fetters us and i believe
men and women need fettering not just
women men also need fettering and
controlling as well because just as our
brother eddie mentioned just now with a
scattergun you know if i had it my way
i'd marry one woman because i i
i said this on one of my podcasts before
one woman i only need one woman to love
and for her to love me that's enough
from a love perspective and a meaningful
relationship but i could have unlimited
sexual partners where i allowed if if i
was allowed to do that you see and this
is why we need fettering and controlling
because this entire discussion has been
themed around the denigration of
sexual urges or protecting our our
sexual impulses in my opinion the only
way to do that is to get rid of birth
control i don't think it'll ever go back
unless that's an interesting point
because that's when you see everything
switch if you look at the divorce rate
graph like when as soon as divorce
spiked at the same time that was when
birth more women were getting on birth
control because you're taking away
because that's the thing like society
takes away the consequence for
everything women do like we have no
consequences for anything if we sleep
around we don't get pregnant because of
birth control even if we do get pregnant
we have abortion even if we do get
pregnant and keep the kid he pays child
support even if we do get pregnant get
married get divorced we get alimony or
child support again yeah and it's like
even if we're bad with our finances and
we're homeless there's women's shelters
i think in general like people like
control we say we don't what we do with
not just with sex with everything really
a little bit of control is good it's
almost like god put these barriers for
sex for a reason in order for these
things like high divorce rates and
children out of marriage and stuff like
that to happen but we have managed to
hack into our biology yeah to create
these like i mean how many how many
shotgun how many shotgun weddings were
there before it was shotgun shotgun
wedding is basically like um dude our
girl gets pregnant right in high school
or something and the dad takes a shotgun
and says mary my daughter oh yeah like
that happened that happened all the time
before birth control yeah and they've
turned out fine and a lot of them built
really beautiful families out of it but
now you know women have to like feel
like he's the right guy even though it's
like you made a kid with him but this is
why this is why in in a lot of the cases
like women are the kind of the
orchestrators of their own demise so
when left to their own devices they can
be quite destructive which is why you
need to absolutely but i think it's part
of the problem is the fact that a lot of
the responsibility in how society
grows is based on women because if women
maintained if the birth control thing
for example wouldn't maintain more
sexual discipline then men are forced to
conform to that standard men will behave
in a way that women allow them to behave
if you're all freeing up then of course
we're going to take it that's you're
buying into what it is it i think will
take a man one man 40 years to
impregnate the entire female population
of how much sperm he produces can i ask
you ladies something if
your
partner
told you one day you can't wear this out
would you secretly
kind of enjoy that
yeah
i i wouldn't what like if
yeah i feel like i wouldn't want to go
out in a way that my partner deems as
disrespectful
i want him to
feel
good where's the line between control
and
and him looking out for you
i don't know i feel like there's like
maybe this is me but i feel like there's
like a healthy in islam it talks about a
healthy jealousy and like you know i do
feel like huh
yeah like a healthy jealousy that men
have over the they're women and i just
feel like
you know if if if my husband feels like
i'm making a bad decision by doing
something i would want him to tell me
yeah i mean it's all about the right guy
like who do you trust to have that
amount of control if you trust him to
have that amount of control like i would
say it's attractive
because a guy with boundaries is
attractive yeah a guy that just lets you
do whatever the hell you push over
and also you represent your partner do
you know what i mean when you go out and
as well if you're going out as a woman
and you're wearing something like that's
extremely revealing and is going to get
you a lot of attention then that's it's
slightly disrespectful towards your
partner because that's not yes the first
time i've heard you'll say that so every
time i've said sound like that in the
past it's like you're a massage
they went crazy on me when i said that
on tick tock but um and it was like um
but yeah no i feel like you should um
especially when you get into a
relationship as well i understand like
you definitely need to change the way
that you present yourself if you're not
already in in line with that i feel like
it's important because you're like okay
so men chase women attract right so by
by that definition say for example
like i would say that
um
like when a man likes a half naked
picture online
um that is the same level of disrespect
as women posting half naked pictures
online so if you're in a relationship
yeah i think the girl is worse yeah
do you know what yeah yeah it's like a
double tap that's like yeah yeah because
that's what i said yeah and that's what
i said in the video i said if you're um
i said it's it's it's just as bad if
you're going to because obviously we so
men they chase right so of course we can
have a problem why you you're doing that
but then women will be like i can post
whatever i want and i can wear whatever
i want well no because that's not the
dynamic because obviously we are
obviously we get approached so really
you're on display you're showing you're
trying to call that energy in yeah it's
disrespectful
but with that said would you delete your
instagram for your man
uh my whole instagram your whole
instagram come off social media i don't
know you already know the answer this is
yeah i
i delete all my pictures
what you might as well delete the whole
account during it no because obviously
we get like little like like educational
things and stuff what you're getting
on instagram no like they have like
little recipes
yeah but i'm sorry you could you could
do that on youtube you could just
youtube it
there's shorts now that was a myth that
was a myth that was a myth let's break
that one let's bring this i'd rather my
relationship over instagram if it was
that important to my partner then i
would rather have my relationship then
it's just a way to allow people to stop
um approaching you because obviously
instagram is also like a marketing it
screams advertising i'm advertising this
all right yeah question before but my
only fans if i would delete it if some
girl yeah if my partner asked me would
say yeah i don't know it depends yeah
but
is that yes
you make money but some girls make money
off instagram then i think that i think
that's a different dynamic because the
thing is is when you bring money into it
like obvious i don't make any of my
money a lot of all of my money is made
offline right or with different things
different things that i do i just go
onto instagram to give my opinion so for
me if my boyfriend was like i want then
it'd be cool but then if you're making
if you make your money online then
that's a bit of a different question
would you expect your mentor to use
instagram for you um
i mean yes if it was that way but i
can't see myself asking him to like i
would i can't see myself but if i'm yeah
if if i if i yeah i would if i asked him
if i had a big problem i would expect it
i don't want to mother my my man like i
don't want to have to tell you to do
things like you should already just also
he should delete it already no no i'm
saying if that's like a thing
i don't want to have to tell you what to
do like i don't want to have to do that
i should be able to trust you enough to
just to just have your instagram yes
that's already so speaking of speaking
of instagram i actually have a clip to
show you guys
so ish if you want to um do the this is
the one from donovan
um so my
do you guys know donovan sharp he he
does these like relationship skits and
so i want to see what the girls think of
like how you would react to this okay i
actually haven't even watched it he just
told me it pertained to this topic so i
guess we'll mind reacting together
so he's gonna show it on the screen we
haven't figured out a way other than
showing it on our phone
[Music]
guys i think we're having an issue with
the clip so i think that we're going to
edit it in but basically the clip was
talking about how
modern women think it's toxic to
have a boyfriend that doesn't let them
go to the club that doesn't
allow them to post half naked pictures
on instagram that sort of thing so i'm
curious from the women um
would you be okay with a relationship
like that that he was showing in the in
the clip
the second one sorry it was like the
first versus the second yeah i'm i
i don't think
a club i can going to see family i'd be
like okay maybe i can do that by myself
there were some reasonable things but
there's certain things like going to the
club when you're in a relationship you
don't need to be there
it's simple um
yeah i think i think as she said going
to see family and stuff like that is not
it's not that important um and i would
like to think i wouldn't give my husband
like a reason to not trust me enough to
not do these things especially around
family and yeah yeah um and there's ways
that i can prove that i am with my
family and stuff like that but in terms
of like clubbing and wearing certain
clothes and talking to the ex as well
yeah that's cool that's crazy
that's mine yeah what do you what what
about you guys what are your
requirements for a girl if you guys are
in a relationship
definitely not speak to your ex look
again i do only found so i can't tell
them don't and it's yeah
only it's not that it's actually the the
the circle that i'm in it
i've i've been doing this for a long
time modeling music whatever so i've
i've been i'm used to it i guess and it
doesn't really bother me maybe because
you guys are not used to it maybe that's
why
i haven't had a reason to be paranoid
then again
yeah i've never really had a reason to
be paranoid if they post like a
if they're posting like selfies and
they're naked that's different to them
posting modeling pictures for example
you know what i mean
um so yeah of course there's plenty of
things that we're not allowed if i don't
think you should wear that i would tell
you not to wear that
clubbing
it depends if there's like a reason why
you have to go like updated models that
would perform at the club obviously
that's the different reason then
obviously you can go
uh
yeah definitely don't talk to your ex
enough so i think yeah the x is
obviously an obvious one that don't talk
to ex that's that's that's a decade
but i think part of the problem with
modern relationships is the fact that
women often try to find
like a unicorn a guy they can do
everything with so i do also believe
that women need their own social outlets
that they can do that doesn't require
their man to be there and that allows
for healthy distance yeah you need space
do you need a bit of space because
otherwise you ever eradicate eroticism
he's your friend he's your the one you
rely on he's your leader he's this
previous relationships weren't like that
so when the woman stayed at home she had
her own social group she'd go off and do
her own things with her own girls and
they'll be left in on devices the
husband comes home how's your day etc
etc when you look for all these
characteristics in one person it's going
to be difficult to find that person
especially if disney fairy tales taught
you to believe that you're supposed to
find these things in your prince
charming so i do believe that women need
their own outlets the club
probably not the best one but do get
together with your girls and do things
but but having said that
when you're in a relationship be careful
of the friends you keep around you
because your friends will to show you
who you are so if your friends are those
people who do that school club and get
drunk and let man poor drink down their
throats then you know you need to change
your friendship group too yeah
i wouldn't like to ha for example i
wouldn't like to have a friend that does
only fans not like a metal yeah no like
i wouldn't like to have so your thing
it's okay i'm sorry i'm sorry but like i
just i don't feel like it makes sense
and i do i feel like when you're around
people who do that kind of thing it's
subconsciously kind of like programs you
into thinking that that's normal and
that's okay and then you might see the
lifestyle the money stuff like that i
don't want that like i don't want a
friend who's around that or does that
where i'm torn is holidays
because ideally in the ideal world i'd
want my girl to be able to go go on
holiday with her girls and not think
nothing of it but if she's trying to
tell me she's getting fresh island or
that from natural nations like blood
[Laughter]
that's a myth i think with the holidays
thing if she's not like wanting you to
be there that's a red flag brav
like do you want to say i wouldn't like
affirmations
well like trust me in my experience yeah
every time i've had the chick and i know
she's rated me high yeah she always
wants me there bro so i have a question
see what about if it's a family vacation
yeah she's yeah
okay
i'm just curious because i i was
thinking about this like how it would
apply in my life and majority i don't
really have a lot of friends so like i
don't think it would matter too much but
i was thinking about my family vacations
that sometimes i don't think the guy
would even want to go
no because they're crazy like we do so
much like people are exhausted by the
end of them like we'll be like mountain
climb like mountain biking climbing like
doing all this [ __ ] and i was just
thinking if like that would be a red
flag too yeah like i've been in a
relationship like one girl i'm thinking
in particular and she always used to
invite me oh come stay at my house with
my family and i just like i don't really
want to be in that like i mean but i
would want my husband to come see my
family yeah my husband yeah
[Laughter]
at what point do you invite them on
family vacation that's what i was
thinking
i don't know i don't know
what i think after they've met your
family yeah i think from then from time
you've introduced them to your family
then that's then that's it every family
occasion after working towards marriage
at that point yeah yeah yeah
yeah 100
i i wouldn't like i'll be honest like i
would have said differently before i
think right but um i wouldn't want to go
on holiday without my man
as much as i want to go with my girls
and stuff i would rather be with my mom
i have a thing but i'd rather be with my
yeah no i i agree with you i just
yeah i feel like people
our family vacations are like
it's like we'll go on all these crazy
adventures and they're so fun it's like
outdoorsy stuff but i'm like i don't
think most people can handle how much we
do on vacation
but the thing is i also think it's a
problem when a woman sacrifices all her
friends for for men i i do say keep the
right friends around you but you'd like
you shouldn't always have to rely on
your man to want to go out and do these
things but i'd like to believe that you
can have your own autonomy and you can
just get together with your girls and
have fun with yeah
you can do that but i think holidays can
sometimes be a bit different because
you're leaving like do you know whatever
extended but don't get me wrong i would
go on a girl's holiday but like at this
point if i was to think who do i want to
be with on holiday more out of my
friends and and my man would always be
your man it would be it would be my man
yeah he would be first yeah and then my
friends would be second well that's
right
that way and if i could like get him out
the first week and then he stays and
then my girls come out and then maybe
some of his boys come out and we could
just do a whole joint thing that would
be more ideal do you know what i mean
i don't know
again i have a different
opinion about the whole holiday thing
because i've dated these models of
musicians that would go on tours and
tourism
you know modeling in other countries is
really fun but to you maybe it seems
kind of dodgy
is that
the red flag if she's like modeling or
touring with her band well i think
modeling and touring is different but
then she'd need to be with a man that
would be okay but they're having a good
time it's not like they're going i'm
just going to do my job and then they're
going to have a good time of course but
you would hope that your partner would
have a good time with it but not that
type of good time but you would hope
that if they were being faithful and it
was for work and then they were going to
have fun but what what do you mean by
good timers in sexy time or like i mean
look
there's holiday that you just go to let
loose drink get drunk maybe do drugs if
that sort of thing and there's that's
opening doors bro yeah i don't agree
with i don't agree with that but there's
always some system which is touring with
your band sorry my immune system will
shut down i think i'll just get covered
on the spot on that yeah
i don't really agree with at least why
you're not inviting me but like when you
go on tour with your band for example
you're gonna have a good time i know
you're going there for work or for your
music for you whatever same with
modeling but you're going to have a good
time but you just need to have a secure
woman then because and i think it's just
partner choice because some people would
be so like like say for example what you
said some people would be happy about
that maybe people that's within your
industry but if you had a woman who
wasn't within your industry then that
may trigger her she might get jealous i
think at that point the woman should
expect the guy to step up and look like
i had to give an example i remember
talking to a woman at work and this was
the most gangster thing i heard a woman
say they've been together for 14 years
so i just questioned i was just probing
that point like i basically cheated on
you
and she said listen he probably has but
as long as he comes home to me he
doesn't bring none of that nonsense home
and i feel secure and happy and i have
no reason to question him then it is
what it is as long as he doesn't bring
that nonsense home yeah you effectively
do what you like as long as as long as
it doesn't come back to haunt me can i
ask the boys a question right because
like um so okay cool
my opinion would you guys say that you
can um
that you can have sex with a woman and
not love her 100 years yeah
okay hello yeah so you guys don't don't
put sex don't associate sex and emotion
but i think with a woman we when when
women cheat it's more emotional if that
if that makes sense yeah cheating is
different from yeah for women because
like i feel like a guy can like
genuinely love you and just slip up
that's what i feel like that's not slip
up he did it he knows what he's doing
yeah what i'm saying the guy will cheat
and love you more yeah
i've heard that because they say like
the other girl is bad so they'll
appreciate you more or something no i
just i just feel like cool like i i feel
like in relationships where the man is
already saying listen this is what it is
like for example andrew tate how he
talks about how he'll just sleep around
with women regardless of whether you
like it or not if you want it stay if
you don't leave in that situation you've
given her an ultimatum she's made the
choice however if we are going into a
monogamous relationship and then you
step out of the relationship to cheat
that is disrespectful like do you feel
like you kind of make the choice though
if you pick that type of guy like come
on we know which guys are going to cheat
we know come on like we we know what you
guys might cheat and if you pick them
it's okay but having said that women
often fall in love what they hear like
how many women could you honestly tell
to their face that this is happening
that's where honor comes in and you as a
man you have to have honor and come with
the honesty of it all like just be like
this is who i am
i accept it do you know who's going to
cheat dude
okay you might you might you might you
might not know but you know who you you
you you know who can't no but we have to
be real and so it's like yeah you know
it's like okay i don't feel bad for an
nba player and like jason derulo's
little thing that's like whining on
social media because she got cheated on
i'm like you're dating jason derulo what
did you think what is gonna happen
but we have to be real in the context of
society by and large i think it's saying
that 40 of men were able to reproduce
and eight percent of women were able to
reproduce
in today's society
only 20 to 30 of men are actively having
sex so if you break that down to the men
who are tall high value etcetera
you have to come to the conclusion that
most women are sleeping for the same men
yeah so then not to be rude but what
makes you so much more special that
you're going to be able to maintain this
or you're going to be able to cater to
all the needs that he wants from a man
in terms of sexual variety of variety
that he's not going to step up not
saying that you shouldn't have that
ideal but i think it's a bit
it's not realistic to believe that the
type of man that you are attracted to
isn't going to have
massive amounts of options but it goes
back to the disney programming man every
chick finishes a princess oh
everyone's fabulous yeah
i think as i said like if you come to
the girl and you are honest about it i
don't see an issue with it because she
gets to make a choice however lying and
manipulation i don't think that is
manipulation
i think so why do you think it's
manipulating because i mean i feel like
cheating like does put women through
like a lot of like emotional like
distress and stuff like that so
in in a way it is manipulation if you
have agreed to be monogamous then it is
not manipulation it's like you're
breaking the promise that's not the same
yeah but but you had the intention of
not staying monogamous anyways
i think i think
like i would say i always aspire to be
the man that doesn't cheat so i do
things that that prepare me for those
situations okay but anything that hasn't
happened here it's just a prediction so
you can never really say that i will
never do it because like it's always
going to be in me to want to do it it's
whether or not a situation that may
occur where one thing goes left or
whatever but you should always try not
to but
for most men to say that it's holy i
mean if you want to stay married say for
50 years it's a long time
no it's a long time to go again but as i
said as i said when children are
involved and you you said the same thing
when children are involved that's a
different story i feel like they're more
likely to cheat after the children it's
way more stressed yeah i mean
like i agree with you i think that's the
ideal but i understand where the men
were coming from because it's like
it's it's a different world because guys
like certain guys
no certain guys get messages every day
they have a whole snapchat list full of
girls ready to go at any time
and so it's like it's not the same
temptations it's a different set of
temptations than it was a hundred years
ago because girls are so easy now but
snapchat's a barrier so imagine just
stepping out with the boys when you're
in front of that person and you're drunk
and you're into whatever whatever like
yeah like you run it you run into an axe
or something a girl you used to hook up
with yeah have you guys ever cheated
no no no
well you have three wives so it's not
cheating
that's not true that's not cheese that's
not cheap you might read it yeah yeah
you cheated yeah all right look at the
confidence that's yeah
no
the worst one i did i had a girlfriend
this was when i was still playing
college football yeah yeah i had a
girlfriend she lived in riley
anyway boom and then like i slept with
two other chicks from pof and the same
man he said plenty of fish yeah finish
the same day and then my girl at the
time she wanted to see me after well i
started feeling guilty in it so i was
like nah nah
did you buy anything
on holiday no
i know bear man that cheated i would
just pay for a holiday or something but
like you deserve this no i was just
well i feel bad but then i don't know
like it's just an opportunist thing in
it the opportunity came i was like yes
after you after you saw how she felt
would you do it again she never found
out no oh she didn't know of course not
okay i mean
do you think she kind of knew like was
she suspicious no no really she had no
idea
wow i hope she doesn't watch this
wait so
who have you ever cheated you you no i
had multiple wives well it's not
cheating though exactly that's what i'm
saying like islam provides a man that
outlet to exercise his peligenous nature
if he so wishes to only if he can
provide obviously well i mean yes there
are there is something called no strings
nikkah which is
where a woman voluntarily forsakes some
of her rights if she finds herself in a
situation where she doesn't want a man
full time let me give you an example
she's been married twice thrice through
two or three times before she's a two
times baby mama of three or four kids
all right and she's got two boys at home
as well and they don't want to see next
man coming into the house yeah boys are
jealous over their moms as it is she's
got a full-time job she's caring for her
mom she's got these kids at home she
doesn't want a full-time husband but she
wants to be able to have experience the
perks of a marriage with a man on a
part-time basis what is she to do
because islam prohibits zina which is
sex outside of marriage right
fornication or adultery
this is a solution for her whereby she
can essentially
marry a man on a on a basis whereby both
parties agree what they are prepared to
bring to the table and it's at her
discretion no one can coerce her into
that for the most part however you're
absolutely right if a man wants to take
on multiple wives gonna have to be able
to take care of her
in that regard yeah so like i say like
islam
as muslim men
we we're given the option to exercise
our politicist natures it's just
controlled feted
it's not really nearly as much as you
like hence why i said i do have a gripe
with those who say high value men can
sleep with whom whoms whoever they want
well you are as much as a contributor to
the problem as as much as you would like
to complain and complain about it you
are contributing to the problem
it doesn't really matter if other guys
say oh high value
it depends on the market brother any day
the market will go after the the guy the
market being women will go after the guy
that's high value and a lot of times the
women know the guy's got other women and
they still have them
it's the average men that are
complaining so that's the difference
yeah remember high value men only
represent one or less the ten percent so
that's that's very minimal men so even
if they were complaining it wouldn't
really matter because their voice would
be insignificant to the vast majority of
men that exist outside of you all right
let me ask you this do you consider
yourselves high value man work in
progress or not at all
have any minds is strictly for our mind
is financial
yeah i mean look
i can let me read the actual pillars
because i have them right here
yeah there's like kevin samuels listed
them so you have to make 10k per month
and you have to have had that for three
to five years other men must accept you
as high value you have to have a network
of high value men you have to be
visibility linkedin level and utility so
you're useful to the group and others so
that's kevin samuel's version of what a
high value man is um i the way he said
that he did not come up with it that
like that's been the definition
throughout all of history bottom line
distinguish yourself from the mass of
men
right and usually for a man that means
we're looking at his finances because
other elements
you can't control you can't control your
height you can't control the size of
your tool you can't control i don't know
your looks for example those are things
that are kind of outside your control so
men tend to be judged none of those
things are available i think men may not
judge them looks as well
no for sure
men men are judged harsher actually for
looks now in 2022 like women women are
raped women are judging men by the way
that men used to judge women and again i
still would say it still goes and it's
based on dating app data and i would say
it still goes back to the development of
birth control because before like women
had to prioritize the guys that could
take care of her but now you can sleep
with the guy get the genes and still be
taken care of literally no matter what
you do you can you can be a single
mother on the street the government will
take care of you or you can just charge
him for the rest of your life so you
don't have to prioritize that anyone
with what falls do you know who he is
yes yes
he's a good content creator yeah very
yeah very interesting stuff yeah i i
agree with a lot of his stuff like i
think it starts
somehow you should i don't know where he
is but he doesn't have a face does he
yeah no he's showing his face no sorry
what's the name yeah he said waffles
yeah i think he's a i think it's
accurate i think it starts with look if
you want like genuine desire otherwise
the girls is just with you for money
because if it's just money the girl is
going to sleep with the mailman the
policeman do you consider castillo a
good looking man i don't i don't really
look at men like that but i can't know
girls ladies
i know when i might look okay the bread
tip brad pitt type of look right sharp
jawline eyes nose and so on i would not
consider castillo a handsome man but i'm
just casting exactly
i know you're talking about it but
castillo's game is so on point
with with women that he's somehow able
to exude a certain type of energy
whereby they gravitate towards him
regardless yeah i think but i think
good-looking men can be very
unattractive i'm not gonna lie to you
like like you can have like a beautiful
face um and like
you know whatever but i i i can find it
repulsive if the way you act is it's
like a guy could be good looking have
you ever have you ever seen a guy that's
really attractive and then he opens his
mouth and he's so and he's so feminine
that you're like oh god never mind yeah
that's exactly why high value can't be
only attributed to finances i think
finance is probably the most important
part but it's high value comes with
characteristics of leadership your
social presence and stepping in a room
and people know when you're there you
know when the high value man stepped in
the room he hasn't even said enough and
you can feel his presence that's the
difference so finances is very important
i don't think that's the only factor
because if you look at today's society
you have a lot of tech nerds who are
rich these men make peas 100 bags a year
100 bags a month or whatever um and they
don't have a clue how to talk to women
these might even get women so they're
still a part of the average men with a
lot of money and those of the men who
are mad angry that they're furious
they're like i've done everything
to to to be deemed high value or what
women would like and i still don't get
yeah the women they do get are like only
there for finances and only they're for
monies users users yeah they are i'm
saying because like even under my videos
sometimes i get comments from the same
example like guys would be like yeah
i've done everything right blah blah
blah and i still don't get girls and
it's like bro like
this whole
high value thing like me personally
because going back to what he was asking
like i don't i wouldn't class myself as
a high value man in that street like
laundry list like but i do well
yeah do you get i'm saying so i guess it
is it depends on who you're asking do
you know higher value should be
according to your own i mean obviously
we've got we've got a higher value right
the term but do we not do you not think
a high value person should be according
to what's high value no no no no no no
it needs to it needs to be by the market
yeah so like because
this is like when girls want to say that
like single mothers can be high values
or like fat chicks can be it's like it's
not what does the market want so and and
you have to have standards so i mean the
whole point is that most people in
general aren't high value most people
are average it's a very small percentage
of people at all that are high value so
even like i mean i would say you have to
have a certain level of income as a guy
to be part of that category the same way
a girl has to be a certain level of fit
and like attract facially attractive to
be part of that category
if you're not like you're just like most
people because most people aren't
other high value women
i mean i wouldn't so there's there's two
schools of thought that i've understood
in red pill and i think you've probably
been in red pill longer than me so you
could tell me if i get this wrong
there's two schools of thought there's
like one that there is no high value
woman
and that basically um the only way you
could be a high value woman is this beer
chosen by a chosen by a high value man
so like when um jeff bezos's wife was
still married to him like that she would
have been a high value woman and then
the other school of thought is that like
it it
they have to be under a certain age and
like a certain level of attractiveness
so like an eight to ten um that's like
20 under 27 or 26 whatever it is but i
think most people agree with the first
one where like she has to be chosen by a
high value man um
my parents could be a technical example
right because my dad's like in the top
one percent of earners right but and my
mom got him when he was young so there's
like two types of high value wives it's
like the one that was there to like
bring him up and usually they're a
little bit more average looking and like
less good looking but she was there from
the beginning she picked them all she
was young so she was so she helped me
no no no my dad was not rich when they
met so but she could see my dad has like
the craziest work ethic i've ever seen
and anyone ever this man's insane he
like
tried to retire and like he's already
started another company because that's
just how he is
and um so but like basically my mom had
a higher sexual market value when she
met him at 18 right and then um his kept
going up and like hers goes down but she
would still be a high value woman
because she got the commitment from the
guy and then the other type is like
basically the hot 22 year old the guy
picks
when he just wants to keep defining his
high value yeah this is what's important
well that's for a woman for a woman it's
that she has to be picked and can keep
the guy because women are measured by
the type of guy they can keep
because i was going to say if we're
going to judge it just on beauty well
beauty is common youth is common
so we can't if we to say that a
beautiful young woman is
high value which means she is rare
essentially right
well there's a lot of i think femininity
i would guess
most people don't agree with the school
of thought that she can be a high value
unless she's been chosen that's just the
only one i've heard actually because you
can't distinguish yourself as a woman in
the west today just by being feminine
agreeable nice you can be nice if you
can make rice
you make rice if you can make rice
without a rasco oh my god i i whatever i
see a super hot like when i was in um
shortage yesterday interviewing people i
would see these beautiful women and
they're so nasty and i'm like that is
the biggest waste of i'm like you could
be i don't care if you want to go the
career route you could be in sales
selling a bunch of [ __ ] to high value
matt i'm like if you want to go the
housewife route you could have just you
could be chilling right now you could do
whatever you want and you're you're
choosing the clubs
it goes back down to like the inflated
like sense of self that you also speak
about like i think because when you are
young and like still beautiful you kind
of like live in the moment and think
that that's never going to go away and
that you're just going to be beautiful
forever and you're always going to have
all these men hit in your line but
that's that's not going to be the case
and you are go your value is going to
decrease as you age and it's going to be
a hard pill to swallow do you think they
realize that though like i think a lot
of them were very hot very beautiful
when they were at 20 and now they're 40
50 they're kind of like still sort of
thinking they are the shits because they
were they
they no they no they know they just are
in denial it's like it's kind of like
fat chicks know they're fat
but they just are like trying to live in
delusion but they know deep down no
one's trying to talk to them
you've noticed a lot of women that like
back in them were 20 years old like
21 whatever
they were getting a lot of attention now
they're not but they still feel like
they deserve the attention like their
ego is still awesome yeah and that's
where they try to compete with younger
women so that's why they give younger
women bad advice like sleep around
do you guys feel like you are more
attracted you um you attracted more men
when you were 21 verse how old are you
sorry i'm 25. okay oh you're 20 i'm 21.
all right you're 21. okay so i'm 32
right and again i genuinely from the
moment i genuinely feel like that i
attract more men now than i did when i
was 23. i bet you if we pulled my
audience with a picture of you from when
you were 21 to now yeah i think they
would pick the 21. let's do it i would i
wouldn't mind it because when i look
back at pictures and i compare them i
look at myself you can you can pull them
up we could just ask the guys here if
you if you have your phone you could
literally just ask the guys
yeah yeah
i promise you now let me see if i can
find one because i genuinely i looked
out
and a couple of my other friends not all
women because i've known women i went to
school with that look like [ __ ] now
mm-hmm that one i've seen were you fat
before um i had a bit more extra weight
on that i'd say the only exception is
but i've never really haven't done you
see that yeah if that is accurate the
way you're saying it oh
when i hear people say i'm 55 years old
and i'm in the shape of my life or i'm
healthier at 55 than i was at 25. that
just means that you were just fighting
out of shape at 25. you don't see any 55
year old nfl stars
football players it just means you were
really badly out of shape when you were
younger so if that exists if this
example is accurate then it just means
you did like michael said you had a glow
up i honestly think most girls peak at
18. like to be honest like because most
girls gain
most girls gain weight in college
like and i know i think guys you guys
can't say this because it's like that's
weird but um
i i don't know i think that most girls
looked better at 18 than they do at 25.
yeah i really still had something to say
about that yeah yeah and it's it's like
it's kind of weird because they're so
young but i just think physically like
they tend to look better completely 18
is too young no not 18 but like what's
before 18.
yeah
but scientifically would you go when
there's more yeah would you go for an 18
year old
yeah no that's a bit too young
of course of course 100 let me say let
me say to you why
look
first and foremost you know what the
legal age of marriage was in the uk
just until two months ago
it was 16 and then two months ago they
changed it to 18 which means that a
a consenting 16 year old so long she had
the consent of her parents as well that
was the only caveat right she could get
married to a 30 40 50 60 year old in
scotland she can still do it she can go
to scotland and she can actually get
married without her parents consent
either i don't think that makes it right
though just because the law says
something does you still have like
free thought you know what do you mean
like just because a 16 year old can get
married to like a 50 year old doesn't
mean that that's a good thing
i'm not see this i'm not moralizing i'm
not saying it's good or it's bad i'm
just i'm simply alluding to the fact
that it can be done in certain states in
america maybe
pearl can actually
allude to this more the legal age of
marriage was as young as young as 14 in
certain states if i'm not mistaken right
14. but this is not this is not the case
yeah but this is the thing the the
reason why i say no to an 18 year old
girl is because more than likely her
immaturity will cause problems yeah for
real yeah and it's long you know i just
i disagree that you know i think most
men would pam young bucks
if it was socially acceptable to do so i
think so a lot of men stopped themselves
from moving to young girls because i
think about this way obviously our cold
approach i'll see a pretty girl on the
street and i'll approach her yeah if i
approach that girl she's 15 i've already
in my head i'm thinking i would have sex
with this girl the only thing that
deterred me was the fact she told me her
age had she have lied it might have been
a different case which means that to
some degree i'm attracted to that girl
most men are like that some men act upon
it others choose not to because of the
moral um standing society puts on him
that's a great point a lot of 15 year
olds look like 21 year olds
they were 15 because they told you i'm
not disputing that like a younger girl's
gonna look good obviously she's gonna
look whatever yeah but i'm saying in
terms of relationship like me dealing
with this girl day in day out yeah yeah
because i heard no no you're saying that
because you know obviously in most cases
i'm not going to say all girls
girls mature faster than men we all know
that yeah so there's in some cases in
some cases i've met girls who are
younger who come correct in the way they
behave the only deterrent the fact is
you're you're young
i can't believe a girl that age but if
i'm being real with myself most of that
and most men will only say that because
of society not because they actually
want to say no because there's mandate
out there that
under the rug there'd be pam youngbox i
think the problem is when you as a man
like in your 30s 40s maybe you actively
chase 18 year olds like all the time
because you know you kind of like sort
of superior you have more control if it
happens if you just go happen to go out
with a girl and she's 18 or 19
then it's okay but if you actively chase
this
when we come to this conversation with
women yeah it's like you're talking like
women are bear stupid so no i don't
a 30 year old comes to 18 year old oh my
god she's this innocent girl that you're
gonna like i'm not saying that men don't
do that because you have to remember and
i say this in being alpha when you men
will be alpha in certain instances so
like a school teacher teacher's alpha in
the classroom that's where he's he's his
most alpha in this situation so he might
use that situation to his advantage so
in in these situations cool he might be
approaching a younger girl for whatever
reason but at the same time are we not
saying that this young girl has a like
she's 18 you're at universe at this
point you should be able to distinguish
with like
yeah so first of all so i'm not facing
you man like it's not as cool as michael
i feel kind of rude i i just think like
if you just do it all the time then you
you you they might not be stupid they
they're not
they might not be immature but you as a
man if you're always chasing them you
you do think that you feel superior to
them because that's why you're chasing
them because they're
but then
what would be the difference between
that him chasing a girl that's 18 and
him chasing the girl that's 22 in both
situations i'm sure he's feeling he
feels the same why is it different when
she's 18 20 22 when she's 22 when do you
okay when do you think
is socially acceptable like a guy should
go for a girl you think it's 18 or do
you think it's younger i think it's 18.
what do you think 18. when it's socially
acceptable no not socially like when do
you think
if it like like it should be legal
what to have sex with her
yeah 18 yeah
it might as well be 18 because me as a
28 year old i can't have six or eight or
like to me it's weird if we're gonna say
18 year old it's weird sorry okay if
we're gonna pull a number
what's the metric or what what metric
are we using to say yeah it should be 18
it should be 21 it should be 16 nations
there's no metric in society it's it's
it's what it's the social norms that's
perpetuated by society so if social
norms change tomorrow then i'm sure
bearman will be like yo think about um
that bad girl baby whatever name is when
she turned 18 i made like six million in
an hour
how many six million men have to buy her
subscription
to make that kind of money
that's bad man that would do that
actively i mean
childhood childhood is a social
construct isn't it like in different
cultures
childhood means different things and
even in the past like in the medieval
ages childhood wasn't really even a
thing so when she became when she had
the first period is when she became a
woman
right you can't really control the two
though because back in the day they had
a lot of experience i think people lived
not didn't live as long i think that's
true
yeah so they had to kind of get going
and also they weren't soft like us like
we're so excited i mean i don't know
because
i i can't just think of anything
even 18 is like weird to me and i know
it's like a societal thing but even that
is like kind of weird and i don't know
why what you as a woman 18 year old man
or no no like like
both honestly both but it's probably
just because of the society i just think
most men lie if i'm just being rude yeah
like baby yeah i agree with you because
when when i was younger i used to get
hit
by old men oh
i remember and i looked young
actually i remember being 16 and getting
hit on by guys and they're like oh it
doesn't matter it's like i remember when
when i went to college i was 17 because
i was a year young for my grade and i
specifically remember there was like one
guy from the law program and whenever i
didn't like i want to talk to a guy i
would just say oh i'm 17 and they'd
usually go away but he was like oh the
age of consent in ohio was 16. yeah
man
done his research
um
desired at what age
yeah
i mean i was kind of ugly when i was
younger but um
[Music]
i think like sixteen
six fifteen now fifteen i was like i
thought it was about fourteen yeah i
looked my hips started coming in i
started to notice men look at me
different than they did before yeah yeah
well i was tall so like i i've been the
same height since like seventh grade so
when i was 14 or 13 like i looked like i
was 20.
yeah yeah yeah so i would say 14
probably
yeah
yeah they're not dangerous i'm gonna
i'm gonna read some super chats oh but
real quick what age do you think
i mean look whatever society you're in
whichever country you're in the society
or you should abide by the laws and
customs of that society if it's 18 it's
18 if it's 21 it's 21. but if we look
from historically speaking
in
all four corners of the globe of the
globe families would marry off their
daughters not long after she got her
first period
that's when she starts looking like a
woman the moment she begins looking like
a woman it's very different hence what i
said to you have 15 year olds who are
dolled up with makeup getting into the
club why if she knows someone as well
especially how can you tell the
difference
back in the days
they were very mature because they went
through [ __ ] you know yes that's about
the mind but that's not i agree with you
that's not really my point of contention
my point of contention is once she looks
like a woman until someone tells you bro
she's 15 you're about to catch a case um
you don't no you're just there
do you understand did you find a picture
is that yeah yeah so pass it to the guys
and then that was um so i'm going to
read super chats pass it pass it to the
guys i'm going to read super chats and
then we'll come back after
okay so guys thank you so much for the
super chats all of these are going
towards studio updates while you're at
it like the video
um we are we have 1 800 people in here
and only 787 likes what are you guys
doing let's get to a thousand likes that
is the number one metric that youtube
uses to push you in the algorithm so
like the video a like is free if you
guys aren't all gonna subscribe i see
you ninja watchers at least like the
video come on okay das token e30 young
girls are competition women don't want
that dash token e30 what is the
alternative to a younger legal girl is a
28 year old community bike better at
least older men have something to offer
younger kids have nothing
i am just jewels fascinating to see the
unwillingness to confront the
possibility of failure not to
acknowledge that it could happen king in
the house looking sharp in that mauve
dress pearl um the green gatsby i'm an
average girl and never felt like i was
the prettiest in any room ever when i
was in my teens so i had to depend on my
intellect when wit more than my looks
edgar reigns fit beautiful inspirational
and the fbi i think could be a high
value woman said by kevin samuels or fit
feminine and friendly honest citizen you
can cheat and love a girl but if you
cheat but if you cheat you just you love
yourself more than your girl because
your hedonistic desires come first over
your girl the green gatsby i let my
partner of three years go out for
meeting new women i was not i'm not
worried or jealous in that situation
because he is very loyal to me
emotionally i tried to get jealous but i
just can't thp network pearl absolutely
great show bravo and congrats on 200k
maurice clark clark two dollar super
chat thank you very much
jason bennett the girl in the middle is
she single i'm six foot six figure six
inches and working on my six f six pack
you are right yeah yeah you want to put
your instagram no i'm okay
okay okay um i think her instagrams and
my stories
send more super chats i'll read it the
green the green gatsby i'm a five at
best when i am fit and healthy and i'm a
two or three on my worst days when i'm
not trying i could look way better but
sometimes i feel like i get more respect
when i'm ugly uglier in male spaces
damian gibson pearl is hot thank you the
green gatsby i'm 27 and with my partner
of three years and seeing things for
what it is rather than what i want them
to be pearl thank you for lifting the
veil of the illusion black is panther a
woman having sex quickly is not the
problem if she moves it's if she moves
on to another man too quickly that's how
she runs up bodies the green gatsby
thank you for the super chat the green
gatsby i wish i had listened to my dad
and my aunt when i was younger rather
than believing the modern western
conventional belief that men and women
expressed sexuality in the same way
alistair horton ffs it's supply and
demand it applies to everything
the rarer it is or the harder it is to
acquire the more it is valued including
sex the great gatsby
i first started to use tinder in 2013
2014 and my first year of university and
genuinely believe that if a guy had sex
with you he is expressing love towards
you boy i was wrong i learned it the
hard way it seems naive yes but i come
from a south asian muslim culture where
i grew up listening to intense love
stories and sex is considered sacred
traditionally over the years of being in
the west for nine years i learned a lot
about relationships between men and
women vincent dacil by isha house vis
vincent dolasal becky g and mcdonald's
grimace on the couch talking about soul
ties through sex and and my eyes rolled
back immediately so much they hit march
oh hit match
match match 5 speed
vood voodoo
body count itself isn't what wrecks an
outlook for happiness lower body count
indicates having being raised with
values that eliminate the need to
attempt a hundred relationships before
you you never learned what to look for
hashtag a present father elia elias
mangi big man ting when are you going to
do a live show here in fiji pearl loving
the show sniper out on all digital
platforms
um vincent dolla style aqua aquaman on
the left doesn't know what a nine is and
most men know those girls aren't those
aren't the girls you wife anyway those
are fun girls only edgar ryze is the
moroccan lady a muslim you must yeah i
am
wonderful illusion pearl can you give a
shout out to my man
maddie great show
vincent docile aquaman on the left is
actually right the grape fantasy is the
most common amongst women that you think
caught me off guard whenever a girl has
said it rose my hubby said i fold i hold
the fort down at home with cleaning and
kids so he's able to focus on work and
his ministry i believe that's what men
want matt butcher ladies were making
make up for attention to get attention
themselves brooke cormier i connect a
lot in spirit it's hard to explain total
bs you do not want to put it into words
because you could get called out okay so
i think that's all the super chats i'm
just gonna refresh the page real quick
just to make sure i didn't miss any guys
like the facebook page like the twitch
page and like this video don't do don't
be bogus okay if you're watching the
video and you've watched if you watch
two or more of my videos and you don't
subscribe we have beef so subscribe
while you're at it flavor community and
chef march
you can tell if she is young because her
conversation will not be fully the same
as a grown woman
the savvy ninja if the goal is to have
kids then the younger the better for
girls if no kids
are the goal then it becomes nuance and
the waters are unclear we may be at a
point where the two are sexually
different sexual marks
okay so i'm going to ask the answer to
the question and then we're going to
close out the show so yeah i would just
wait a second yeah so um i'm just
curious from the men what do you think
pictures
no yeah
no you loadouts though
so you can actually glowed up yeah yeah
yeah yeah congrats
oh really congrats oh wow okay oh thank
you that like never happens
no i wasn't i was just stop i'll show
you if you want yeah let me speak into
the mind i'm a bit i'm a bit slimmer now
but um
let me zoom in
i just think you found your look yeah i
think maybe that's what it was okay i
see i see yeah okay um so guys why don't
you say any clothing closing thoughts
that you have a bunch of you are on
social media today so tell people where
they can find you in the chat so you can
see youtube mahadithijani just type my
name i've been tagged on pearlstory you
can find all my links directly from
there
okay cool lydia rose and if you just
type in she is lydia rose you can find
me um on there and on tik tok and on
probably a few blog pages too
um i don't do like any of this type of
content on social media but yeah yeah
no don't slide on it yeah i feel you're
gonna make the mistake say your
instagram
[Laughter]
all right well uh michael king on
youtube
michael king on youtube make sure you
subscribe to my channel always posting
every day so make sure you subscribe um
and also the instagram ambitions of
power on instagram yeah make sure you
give that following uh big up to
just pearly things yeah i mean with a
guess
well he's not should know me but now
who's underscore eddie underscore
um hit me up you want to come on the
show feminist listen come through stop
being scared yeah give me a shirt yeah
let's get debating
um obviously also on the domino effect
podcast is awesome you want to go tune
in there subscribe and all that good
stuff but listen hit me up feminists
stop running away yeah don't show up and
then leave literally so you need to see
your exit
she didn't really want to she was scared
at first i kind of convinced her and
then for some reason she just couldn't
handle it so she left
yeah yeah you got techie she asked one
question was like yeah i don't want to
be involved
and subscribe to my only fans
let us know if you make money from only
fans of this as well oh okay
i do
i do have a 10 female audience so you
never know thank you ladies
okay guys thank you so much for watching
this show um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and sign up for our
memberships guys their memberships is
going towards our rent it's so important
because it makes me know that i can
afford a bet a bigger place next year we
have a consistent form of income every
month plus at the 10 tier you get some
lit vlogs like honestly we are the
funniest people ever and you are going
to get the best behind the scenes
content
um also guys like our facebook page like
our twitch page subscribe to the channel
like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time
bye
that's a wrap
it's hot
turn these lights off